Ich bin gerade aufgestanden.
Wir müssen ja gleich noch eine Runde Social Eating machen.
Ich wollte erst mal was futtern.
Ich habe heute mein Mikrofon auf dem Tisch stehen.
Ich hoffe das Geklapper von Maus und Tastatur ist nicht zu laut, wenn doch muss ich mal gucken
wie wir das machen.
Ich muss jetzt gerade mal einen Stream reinhören ob das so passt.
Ich muss jetzt mal hier testen, wenn ich Tasten drücke ist es zu laut oder?
Naja das zackt.
Wir probieren das mal aus, weil ich habe seit Freitag irgendwie so komische Geräusche im
Ohr.
Und wenn ich mein Headset aufsetze und mich selbst höre, was ich ja einstellen muss,
dass ich überhaupt, na sonst schrei ich ja total rum, dann hallt das so rechts im Ohr,
das zackt ganz schön.
Ich war am Freitag beim Hals, Nasen, Ohrenarzt und da habe ich gesagt, ja dann wollen wir
mal Ohr aussaugen, Ohr spülen und sonst was.
Das habe ich gemacht, das ist wirklich besser als es nicht.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt das Mikrofon vor mich gestellt, gucken ob das funktioniert.
Und ich weiß auch nicht wie viel ich heute erzählen werde, ich muss erst mal aufwachen.
Zumindest ein Spiel, wo ich mich schon seit, eigentlich seit dem ersten Teil drauf freue,
wo ich es eigentlich kaum erwarten konnte, dass es rauskommt und ich jetzt den Release
total verpasst habe, ist Divinity Originals in 2 und ich dachte mir, bevor ich das jetzt
für mich spiele, für alle die es interessiert haben es wahrscheinlich nicht schon mal gespielt,
mache ich einfach mal den Streben an.
Ich habe vorher ganz kurz schon mal reingeguckt, ich habe auch die Beta mal 5 Minuten oder
so gespielt, ich habe überhaupt keine Ahnung.
So jetzt muss ich nur mal gucken ob die Lautstärke okay ist, von meinem Zeug zu Desktop Audio.
Ja, hallo an alle die schon am Start sind, aber ich würde sagen, als erstes müssen wir
mal einen Hauptcharakter erstellen.
Die zwei Sachen gab es in der Beta nicht, ich habe übrigens den Stream auf 1008p gestellt,
ich glaube das ist ganz gut, weil da tut sich eh nicht viel hier in dem Game, sondern
das ist nicht so, dass das jetzt wie in Battlefield der ganze Bildschirm immer wackeln würde,
außer hier jetzt.
Wir spielen den klassischen Modus, ich glaube das ist schon schwer genug.
Und da war so eine Frage an die Leute die da sind, habt ihr den ersten Teil gespielt?
Und für alle die das nicht gespielt haben, ich weiß nicht wie es genau jetzt im zweiten
Teil ist, aber das ist relativ slow paced.
Also das ist eher was Richtung Baldur's Gate als Richtung, wie hieß das, Dragon Age, Inquisition
oder so, wie das letzte hieß.
Also das ist so ein recht klassisches rundenbasiertes RPG.
So, erstmal müssen wir den Hauptcharakter erstellen und ich habe mir im Vorfeld schon
überlegt, am liebsten würde ich hier einen Zwerg Bersi spielen, das Problem ist sowas
gibt es in dem Game nicht, deswegen versuche ich mal irgendwas zu basteln, boah sieht der
hässlich aus, Alter das kann ich mir nicht geben, aussehen die alle hässlich aus, ja
das sieht schon besser aus, lull, so und was ich auch im Vorfeld gelesen habe, man soll
hier nicht diese Benutzer definierten nehmen, sondern, am besten und das habe ich auch in
der Beta damals gesehen, die deutsche Übersetzung ist übrigens noch Beta, was ist eigentlich
der Unterschied zwischen Ritter und Kämpfer?
Also wenn das so ähnlich ist, wie im ersten Teil, dann gibt es eigentlich zwischen den
ganzen Presets, die man hier auswählt, eigentlich keinen großartigen Unterschied, außer ein
paar Punkte beim Start vom Charakter, man kann den Charakter im Endeffekt später genauso
bauen, wie ein anderes Preset wäre, also eigentlich ist es vollkommen egal, wie gesagt, wenn das
so ist wie im ersten Teil, so, ich hatte mir schon mal die Intro Videos der einzelnen Charaktere
angeguckt auf YouTube und irgendwie muss ich sagen, am besten hat mir hier der Pirate Zwerg
gefallen, ich weiß persönlich halt, wie man das jetzt am besten, auch mal gucken, mal gucken
ob es deutsche Vertonung gibt, die Skills kann man später auswählen, guck mal wie ging
das, man kann hier die Fähigkeiten auswählen, also eigentlich ist es vollkommen egal was
man auswählt beim Starten, wie gesagt, wenn das so ist, wie im ersten Teil, so, wen haben
wir sonst noch zur Auswahl, also es gibt hier einmal einen Zwerg der, gibt es hier noch
mehr Text, ein Piraten Zwerg, ein Untoter Zauberer und das sind die Charaktere, die
quasi eigene Hintergrundgeschichte haben, das heißt, wenn man das Spiel das erste Mal
spielt, sollte man einen von denen auswählen, weil es einfach schlicht und ergreifend sonst
nur die Hälfte der Story ist und für weitere Anläufe kann man dann hier quasi komplett
Benutzer der Fähigkeiten herstellen, also was haben wir, Piraten Zwerg und Untoter Zauberer,
also dann eher sowas hier, dann haben wir einen ehemaligen Kreuzritter, dann haben wir
eine Bardin, die von irgendwelchen Sachen heimgesucht wird in ihrem Kopf, aha, dann
das Video kann ich mich noch erinnern, Talente Untoter, was muss man lernen um Untoter zu
lernen, no second plan, ne ich hab meine Placements nicht gespielt, wisst ihr übrigens hier die
Lautstärke von Desktop Audio zu meinem Gelaber, ist das ok, für mich ist nämlich den Titten
zu laut, aber das muss bei euch nicht so sein, ne ich hab nicht weiter programmiert an dem
Screenshot Tool bis jetzt, das machen wir auch nur hier on stream, dann haben wir noch
der rote Prinz, das ist laut Herkunftsgeschichte irgendwie ein ehemaliger König von irgendeinem
Echsenkönigreich, der jetzt in Ungnade gefallen ist, aha, das sieht mir eher aus als wäre
das eine Mille, also Nahkampfklasse, so von den, na wobei, eigentlich kann man jeden Held
auf jeder Art spielen, war im ersten Teil auch schon so, also die Übersetzung ist doch
ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig, du bekommst bloß eins Überredung von Zauberlied, aha,
was sagt mir das jetzt, Talente, Komplex, ich glaube die Übersetzung ist, da steht
nicht nur Beta dran, dass die deutsche Übersetzung Beta ist, so, oh die sieht aber ganz schön
dünn aus, dann haben wir noch ein Elf, wie heißt das auf Deutsch, Spitzbube, ein Elf
Spitzbube, ja die Elfen in diesem Universum sind ein bisschen abweichend von Elfen aus
anderen Fantasy-Universen, das sind nämlich Kanibalen, weiß auch nicht warum, was sie
sich mal gedacht haben, aber wir nehmen den Zwerg, ich will den Zwerg spielen, Zwerg
ist geil, ich spiele immer Zwerg, wenn es Zwergen gibt und wir spielen den Zwerg mal
wirklich, ich versuche jetzt mal so was ähnliches zu bauen, wie ich mir vorgestellt habe,
und zwar, ich wollte einen Zwerg Bersi spielen, aber das gibt's hier ja in dieser Form nicht,
deswegen versuchen wir mal was, einen Krieger zu basteln, der sich irgendwie verwandeln
kann oder sowas, hallo Nils, ne jo, so, komm mal weiter, Erscheinungsbild lassen wir einfach
mal so wie es ist, wie gesagt, falls Tastatur und Maus zu sehr rumklappern, müsst ihr befreit
sagen, dann muss ich gucken, ob ich doch aufs Headset umsteige, wobei das halt für mein
ordentlich gerade das Beste ist, so der Frasier guckt zu, krasser Shit, so, tauschen, also
man hat am Anfang, man müsste eigentlich mehr Attribute kriegen, aber wir machen den
ganzen, machen den ganzen Klempel mal weg hier, Warfare lassen wir da, aber wir wollen,
wir wollen Polymorph, das heißt kann mich verwandeln, das ist gut, das wollen wir haben,
wie gesagt, Startpunkte waren im ersten Teil auch ziemlich sinnlos, das ist übrigens irgendwie
auch das einzige Fantasy-Universum, wo Zwerge Base-Attribut Schleichen haben, also die haben
da schon ein bisschen von der Norm abgewichen, mit quasi fleischfressenden Elfen und schleichenden
Zwergen, vielleicht nicht so ganz 0815, so, also den Punkt können wir nicht wegmachen,
was nehmen wir denn hier, ne, das soll irgendwie einer meiner Zauberer später machen, Items
identifizieren, mehr Loot, mehr Loot ist nicht verkehrt, kann ich mich noch dran erinnern,
das Talent war aber im ersten Teil ziemlicher Crap, ich muss mal gucken, ob ich überhaupt
Follow Notification und Chat und so Zeug eingeblendet habe, ja passt, ja Fabian, mach
dir nix draus, ich bin auch gerade erst aufgestanden, immer richtig zurechtungsfähig, kann man eigentlich
mit einfachen, mit offenen Fähigkeiten starten, also sprich, ich wähle einfach nicht alles
Böse Taten, das hieß aber auch irgendwie anders, so gucken wir mal an die Skills, genau,
was wollen wir haben, ich hab irgendwas im Hals, ist ja schlimm, so ne Range Attack ist
denke ich mal gar nicht verkehrt, das brauchen wir, das kenn ich noch aus dem ersten Teil,
absoluter OP Skill gewesen, kann man quasi für zwei Aktionspunkte über einen halben
Bildschirm Chargen und Gegner umwerfen, das Gutes brauch ich, Scheiß auf Schild werfen,
wobei, Moment, ist hier nicht das Gleiche, ok das ist das Gleiche, dann brauchen wir
das doch nicht, oh Stelzen, Stelzfähigkeit, ist auch nicht verkehrt, das nehmen wir noch,
der Stelzzwerg ist am Start, oder nehmen wir das, ich glaub wir nehmen das, oder wir machen
es ganz klassisch hier einfach, dass wir ein Schild zum werfen haben, wir nehmen das jetzt
einfach mal kostet, drei Punkte, ok wir brauchen vielleicht einen Skill, den man öfter einsetzen
kann, so, jetzt können wir hier noch einen Punkt vergeben, in was stecken wir das rein,
tauschen, tauschen, das ist eher was für irgendwie, also nicht jetzt unbedingt für den Haut drauf
Zwerg oder, überreden, überreden, da kann bestimmt gut überreden, da sagt einfach ich
hau dir aufs Maul, dann ist der Gegner instant überredet, den Rest brauchen wir eh nicht
das ganze Schleichzeug da, überreden, also im ersten Teil war das glaube ich so, man
hat jedes Level hier Punkte bekommen und jedes zweite Level Talentpunkte, so Talente müssen
wir uns auch noch als aussuchen, standardmäßig, das gab es im ersten Teil auch, standardmäßig
hat man hier wohl Opportunist, das heißt, das Game hat rundenbasierte Kämpfe, wenn
ein Gegner an einem vorbei läuft und man steht quasi in Schlagreichweite haut man
ohne dass man Aktionspunkte verbraucht, das ist für Nahkampfcharaktere ziemlich gut,
alternativ können wir auch, das passt zum Hau, also das ist ultra wichtig gewesen im
ersten Teil, dass man einen Charakter hat, der mit Hirn reden kann, weil man hat extra
Quest gekriegt, extra Items, Hinweise und alles, moin an alle die jetzt neu dabei sind,
ich sehe gerade 42 Leute zu mir, wie ich den Zwerg zusammen klicke, das will ich aber nicht
unbedingt hier mal im Hauptcharakter geben, das kriegt dann später jemand anderes, also
das finde ich eigentlich ziemlich gut für einen Nahkampfcharakter, dass wenn ein Gegner
an einem vorbei läuft, dass man dann ohne Aktionspunkte draufhauen kann, was haben wir
sonst noch, das brauchen wir nicht, fliehen, wir wollen nicht fliehen, wir spielen normale
Schwierigkeitskarte, da muss man nicht fliehen, irgendwie Dual-Wield oder sowas brauchen wir
auch nicht, das gab es im ersten Teil glaube ich auch, da konnte man Leben absaugen, aus
Blutfützen wenn man drin steht, zwar auch sehr situationsbedingt, mehr Leben ist nicht
verkehrt, aber das ist eher so ein Endgame Talent würde ich mal sagen, das gab es auch
im ersten Teil, das ist ziemlich sinnlos wenn man Party spielen will, das ist auch Mist,
das kann man auch später irgendwann nehmen, Food werde ich wahrscheinlich eh nicht benutzen,
wenn es so ist wie im ersten Teil, oh das brauchen wir, oh das ist nice, das ist nice,
ich vermute mal, ich muss erstmal gucken ob das das macht was ich mir so denke, äh, nicht,
ich hätte jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass ich hier mehr Fähigkeiten auswählen kann,
so liest sich das für mich zumindest, guck mal, steht doch da, 3 extra Punkt, die Beschreibung
ist total hängen geblieben, die Beschreibung ist echt total hängen geblieben, aber ich
gehe davon aus, dass man anstatt 3 Fähigkeiten sich mehr Fähigkeiten merken kann, das Talentsystem
ist ein bisschen so wie man das früher noch von Baldur's Gate kennt, man muss Bücher
finden mit Spells drinnen und die kann man sich dann abschreiben und dann kann man sich
nur eine gewisse Anzahl an Spells merken, also man kann in seinem Buch ganz viele Spells
haben und man kann bloß immer eine gewisse Anzahl mitnehmen und ich lese das so, dass
man hier quasi mehr mitnehmen kann, aber ich kann hier nicht mehr auswählen, das ist ziemlich
bescheuert, dann ist es wahrscheinlich eher was für später, dann bleiben wir hier standardmäßig
mal bei dem, was haben wir sonst noch, parieren brauchen wir nicht, Pfeile brauchen wir nicht,
Granaten brauchen wir nicht, Rätsel, ja, das müssen wir auf jeden Fall in einem Charakter
von uns später geben, Aktionspunkte pro Runde, so wie da eine maximale Aktionspunkt um eins
wenn am Leben, das ist bestimmt auch nicht schlecht, das kann man bestimmt auch schlicht
und ergreifend einfach jedem Charakter geben, wir bleiben hier einfach bei, das für einen
Tank ist es nicht schlecht, so, Eats, hier können wir nichts ändern, weil das ein vorgefertigter
Charakter ist, mit Hintergrundgeschichte und eigenem Voice Acting und allem, Andiversum,
Heimax hast du auch den Eindruck, dass der PC für viele Spieler wieder attraktiver gegenüber
Konsolen wird, ja, ein deutscher seit Jahren schon, also eigentlich seit Release von PS4
und Xbox One, so parallel und dazu kam dann noch das Xbox One und PS4, ja, wenn man mal
von der letzten, wenn man sich die Generation davor anguckt, meiner Ansicht nach ganz schöner
Flops sind, vor allem die Xbox One, dann wundert mich das auch nicht mehr, so, die Instrumente
haben soweit ich das gelesen habe übrigens keinen Einfluss irgendwie auf den Kampf, das
ist einfach nur wenn der Charakter irgendwie eine besonders geile Aktion reißt, dann wird
das dann halt gespielt, so, gut, dann würde ich sagen fangen wir mal an, die ersten 5
Minuten habe ich in der Beta schon gespielt und gestern mal installiert, aber wirklich
Ahnung habe ich nicht, Stärke plus 1, Konstitution plus 2, das drehen wir mal um, komm scheiß
drauf, wir machen Stärke plus 2, bam, wir sind ein sicker Zwerg, ach Moment, ich habe
ja einen Punkt mehr, weil ich Polymorph ausgewählt habe, ja dann machen wir einfach 2, so, easy,
go go, oh man kann den Namen vom Held ändern, das wundert mich jetzt, weil das ja eigentlich
quasi ein eigener, ein vorgefertiger Charakter ist, mit wie gesagt eigener Story, eigenem
Voice Acting und alles, ne wir lassen das mal so, bestie, bestie ist so, wenn das passt,
Rare Parrot, jawoll, los gehts, sehr lauter Montag, sag ich gleich was zu, jetzt müssen
wir uns erstmal Story angucken, die Story im ersten Teil bringt ziemlich an Müll, gleich
mal gesagt, Woodface, oh nein die Welt geht unter, wie untypisch für Fantasy Spiele,
very good, zu leise?
Also für mich ist es fast schon zu laut, aber ich habe eh gerade Probleme im Ohr.
Aufstehen, dicker Zwerg.
Eine Lautstärke müsste eigentlich so passen.
Ging Kameradrehen im ersten Teil auch?
Konnte man im ersten Teil die Kamera drehen, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr.
Controls sind noch ziemlich ähnlich.
Erstmal alles crammen.
Und ich tue euch das nicht an, dass ich jetzt irgendwie alle Bücher lese oder so.
Wir crammen das einfach.
Alles crammen.
Braucht man das Zeug überhaupt?
Nein.
Egal, alles crammen.
Man kann kaum die Game-Voices hören, okay?
Ich mache jetzt mal ein bisschen lauter.
Das Problem ist, dass das Game eben den Sound ausmacht.
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Moment.
Ich muss das jetzt erstmal hier umstellen.
Und zwar auf simuliertes Vollbild.
Nein, Fenstermodus.
Und dann stellen wir das Ganze nämlich einfach mal ein bisschen kleiner.
Also nicht wundern, dass es jetzt scheiße aussieht.
Ich muss das nämlich einstellen, dass ich nebenbei OBS angucken kann für Lautstärke.
Das kann man tatsächlich noch ein bisschen lauter machen.
So, ich denke, jetzt passt das ganz gut.
Stellen wir uns wieder zurück auf simuliertes Vollbild, was auch immer.
Jawoll.
Auf geht's.
Was ist bitte simuliertes Vollbild?
Keine Ahnung.
Sollte mal gucken, wie jetzt die Voice-Lautstärke ist.
Ich höre mir das mal kurz in der Stream-Vorschau an.
Ja, ich glaube, das geht.
So, was ist hier los?
Oh, die wird gebashed.
Die wird jetzt richtig gebashed gleich, sobald ich Waffen habe, die weggeklatscht.
Ich bin kein... also, auch wenn mein Background Edelmann ist, werde ich mich wahrscheinlich
nicht sehr Edelmann-mäßig verhalten.
Ich hau ab.
GG.
Was?
Mordr?
Oh, es gibt Donations.
Apfelschorle, 580, danke für die 5 Euro.
Endlich finde ich mal meinen Weg in deinen Stream.
Danke für die 5 Jahre, geiles YouTube-Entertainment.
Da weiß ich immer nie, was ich drauf sagen soll.
Da weiß ich immer nicht, was ich drauf sagen soll, aber danke für die Donation.
Ich müsste auf YouTube mal wieder ein bisschen mehr Videos machen, ne?
Natürlich gucken wir in den Raum rein.
Ich werde euch ganz bestimmt nicht helfen.
Nein, wir lesen jetzt nicht den Gedichtsband.
Ein leeren Erwachter.
Ich hab die Beete auf Englisch gespielt, da hieß das Voidwalker, ne, Voidwoken hieß das,
genau.
Also passt ja so ungefähr.
Ich will mit dem gar nicht reden, soll mich in Ruhe lassen.
Ich werde ihnen auch garantiert nicht helfen, irgendwelche Sachen aufzuklären.
Source ist in dem Game quasi sowas wie Magic, wenn ich das noch so richtig zusammenkriege
aus dem ersten Teil.
Na dann.
In deinem Zimmer, als das Mörder geschah.
Du warst die ganze Zeit schlafen.
Es hat nicht gemischt.
Du bist einer der einzigen
unvergesslich unvergesslichen Menschen
auf dem Schiff.
Es ist sicherlich ein Mörder in deinem Schlaf.
Ich habe mir gedacht,
du kannst mir eine gute Lüge bringen.
Wie geht es dir mit einer brillanten Goldkarte?
Einen im Schlaf Leute unbringend kann ich noch nicht
Na, nicht rum Ich will was bashen
Also in der Beta konnte man noch alle angreifen, hatte aber Waffen und so das geht jetzt nicht mehr
Ich helfe euch bestimmt nicht.
Ganz wichtig, wir müssen alles looten, was irgendwie so aussieht, als könnte man es looten.
Also ich kann das machen, wie ihr das wollt.
Normalerweise bin ich jemand, der Dialoge relativ schnell durchklickt.
Ich lese das immer ganz kurz und so, ha, ich weiß um was es geht, drücke eine Antwort.
Ich bin da relativ schnell.
Ihr wollt, kann ich die Dialoge langsamer laufen lassen, sodass man es lesen kann.
Oder ich mach das hier so mit meinem Pace und klicke die Dialoge durch.
Man kriegt trotzdem mit, um was es geht.
Das hier am Anfang ist eh nicht so wirklich wild.
Da kriegt man jetzt quasi alle Charaktere mal ein bisschen vorgestellt und Schlafsack.
Oh, das ist wichtig, das brauchen wir.
Da kann man nämlich, wenn man einen Schlafsack hat, kann man nämlich rasten und kriegt Leben wieder.
Das ist wichtig, das braucht man.
Obwohl ich wirklich sagen würde, das sieht eher aus wie eine Isomatte.
Baschen, genau so wie Baro baschen.
Wie euch vielleicht auffällt, sind das die Typen, die ich auch hätte am Anfang auswählen können als spielbarer Charakter.
Also das sind später die, die ich auch in meiner Party kriege.
Könntest du schon mal dein Haar ansatzzeiten, Def?
Gibt doch genug Videos, wo man mich sieht.
Bei dem konnte sich der Sprecher aber auch richtig auslassen, oder?
Der Sprecher muss auch ganz besonders tief und irgendwie besonders männlich reden, das ist wichtig.
Eigentlich ist mir das vollkommen egal, dass irgendjemand auf dem Schiff umgebracht wurde.
Ich würde sie alle baschen.
Oh, Schlüssel, Schlüssel, wichtig.
Küchenbrett, das braucht man unbedingt mitnehmen.
Man kann...
Wie ging das denn?
Also es hat ein relativ komplexes Crafting-System und Kochsystem und sowas.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob man das auf dem normalen Schwierigkeitsgrad überhaupt braucht.
Messer, richtig.
Ausrüsten.
Kann man diesen Helm irgendwie?
Nee, der Helm ist cool, den lassen wir.
Kann man hier durch? Speichern?
Nee, ist zu.
Der Master-Crabber, der Gaston ist da.
Gaston, wo warst du denn gestern?
Schlafsack? Ich weiß nicht, ob sich das abnutzt, deswegen nehmen wir mal lieber ein bisschen mehr Schlafsäcke mit.
Außerdem hat man unendlich Inventar, so viel wie man Stärke hat, das ist echt praktisch.
Einmal, kann man mit einem Einmal... Einmal ist ein Helm, okay.
Perfekt.
So was, ich glaube... Nee, dann behalte ich lieber meinen ursprünglichen Helm auf.
Ja guck mal, der andere Helm ist deutlich besser als der Einmal.
Geh weg!
Ich bin gefürchteter Piratenzwerg, ich beantworte nicht irgendeinem Typ was.
Genau. Bam!
Ich will nicht mit dir reden.
Das sind wahrscheinlich total nutzlose NPCs.
Also die hier, das wissen wir schon aus der Charaktererstellung, weil das sind halt die, die ich auch auswählen konnte.
So, gibt's noch was zum Looten? Looten, wichtig, haben wir schon alles gelootet.
Dann reden wir mit denen hier jetzt.
Nope.
Moin Mr. Ringels.
Wer ist lose?
In dem Game ist kein NPC nutzlos, okay. Also im ersten Teil gab es ganz schön viele nutzlose NPCs.
Ja, eigentlich will ich hier nur raus.
Ja, die wird der LordStory von Inkwilt in Dämonenheim gesucht oder sowas.
CU. Speichern. Jetzt müssen wir den ganzen Kram nochmal machen, falls wir verrecken.
Bier. Bier. Bier. Bier kann man als Zwerg nie genug dabei haben.
Bier. Und vor allem bleibe ich ihm jetzt erstmal sein Bier weg.
Kann man das trinken?
So, jetzt habe ich eigentlich alle NPCs durch, den hier noch.
Das ist der...
Ist das? Ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist der...
Dieses Assassin-Fiech, aber es ist nicht. Gab es zumindest in der Beta noch nicht.
Ach, das ist Fane, das ist der Untote Zauberer, okay.
Der sieht hier gar nicht so untot aus, muss ich mal sagen.
Vielleicht wird er jetzt ja gleich den Löffel abgeben und danach ist er untot.
Mein Zwerg ist besoffen, so wie sich das gehört.
Die Radar hängt.
Was geht mit dem ab?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so toll ist, wenn die sich hier gerade befummeln auf dem Schiff.
Wie weit ist das im Game Optik Jellyfish? Ich habe gerade angefangen vor 20 Minuten.
Oh, wenn ich den Bildschirm wechsle, dann geht der Sound weg.
Das sagt.
Also entweder ist das Absicht oder die Übersetzung ist hier wirklich ein bisschen holprig.
Es ist ergotzlich euch kennenzulernen, ist klar.
Genug gelabert.
So, haben wir alles gelutet.
Gibt es noch was zu looten?
Nope.
Das Game hat übrigens einen Koop. Kannst du noch daran erinnern, wo wir damals Baldur's Gate gespielt haben?
Haben wir nie fertig gespielt, nur irgendwie zu 80 Prozent.
Dann richtig guten Koop.
Alles top.
Ich meine, ich bin immer ein Piratenzwerg. Da ist man nicht freundlich.
Karsten, das glaube ich nicht, dass du das da hast, weil das ist der zweite Teil.
Der kam erst vor zwei Tagen raus.
Speichern.
Oh, crabben. Alles crabben.
Alles crabben.
Ich mache das mal für dich stellvertretend, Karsten. Alles crabben.
Okay, das Zeug ist noch nicht mal Geld wert, das muss ich nicht crabben. Aber Essen kann man crabben.
Kürbissuppe crabben. Schinken crabben.
Kann man hier durch? Nope.
Hallo, ich will hier durchlaufen. Ach, das geht nicht, oder was? Na gut.
Hallo, Pille-Palex.
Ja, aber Karsten, das ist beschränkt durch wie viel Stärke mein Charakter hat. Ich will den echt komplett zumüllen.
Fabian sagt immer, dein Inventar in BDO sieht auch total zugemüllt aus.
So ist das halt, wenn man Master-Crabber ist.
Wenn ich irgendwann mal Custom Emotes habe, Karsten, dann gibt es hier auch so eine Crabber-Zange als Emote im Chat.
Wie darfst du das nur spammen?
Okay, das ist die aus dem Intro.
Das sehe ich auch so, ich will sie alle bashen.
Ich helfe euch doch nicht, seid ihr denn total bescheuert?
Ja, das ist Meuterei, auf geht's.
Irgendwie kommt mir der Sprecher übelst bekannt vor.
Ich muss gleich mal gucken, oder was? Der Sprecher kommt mir übelst bekannt vor.
Ich werde gebasht.
Ich würde sagen, das sieht nicht gut aus.
Ich habe jetzt gehofft, es gibt vielleicht ein ordentliches Schwert, aber dann nehmen wir jetzt eben das Messer am Stock.
Im ersten Teil hatten die so richtig hängen gebliebenes Suchrätsel teilweise.
Da musste man dann hier so gucken, so ohne Scheiß so hier muss man gucken, weil dann hier irgendwo ein Schalter war und sowas.
Ich hoffe, das haben sie jetzt nicht wieder.
Gibt es hier noch was zu crabben? Was ist hier drinnen?
Nope, nichts zu crabben.
Hier unten haben wir ja schon alles gecrabt.
Hier unten haben wir ja schon mehr oder weniger alles gecrabt, wir gehen jetzt hoch.
Das Beste an dem Game ist, zumindest vom ersten Teil, die ganzen Umgebungseffekte.
Wenn man Zaubersprüche einsetzt, hat das alles immer ein unterschiedliches Element.
Die wirken zusammen, sprich wenn ein Gegner hier nass ist und ich mache den Elektro-Zauber drauf, wird er gestunt.
Wenn ich hier Gift rein mische in Feuer, dann explodiert das.
Ich kann natürlich jetzt auch auch ein Wasserfass nehmen und hier aus Feuer legen und dann geht es aus und so was in der Richtung.
Dann gibt es dann Regenzauber-Zauber-Sprüche, da kann ich dann Feuerflächen halten.
Und wenn ich in den Dampf wieder Elektro rein mache, dann gibt es dann elektrisch geladene Wolke und so.
Das Kampfsteam ist richtig geil gemacht.
No Ey
Ooo
Lol
Pfeile brauch ma nich, kurzer Stock
Bier
O minus eins. Intelligenz wanne man besoffen is
Taxi das ist bei nem Zwerg eh nich so wild
Ich habe kein Schlüssel, da sind aber Gegner drinnen. Zumindest, naja. Kann ich da drüben?
Wie komme ich hier rein? Wie komme ich hier rein? Oh Gold, oh das bringt viel Kohle.
Zack, wie viel bringt das? Nix. Okay, weg damit.
Hier ist garantiert irgendwo ein Schalter versteckt, ohne ein Schlüssel liegt drum,
aber man kann auch einfach die Tür einschlagen. Das werde ich jetzt mal machen.
Ich werde jetzt die Tür einschlagen. Ich rüste dafür diesen komischen Dolch aus, den ich eh nicht brauche und schlage jetzt die Tür ein.
Bam. Easy. Zack, Tür einschlagen. Also man kann entweder Schlüssel suchen und man kann auch die Tür einschlagen.
Das Problem ist, Tür einschlagen verbraucht ziemlich viel Ausdauer von, guck man sieht schon, das sind 5 Haltbarkeit drunter.
Das heißt, wenn das eine ordentlich starke Tür wäre, schlage ich 20 Minuten und meine Waffen gehen kaputt.
Das heißt, es ist in der Regel immer besser, man sucht sich den passenden Schlüssel oder NPC, der einem Türen aufmachen kann.
Die werden jetzt gebashed.
Äh, Master, äh, der, äh, Carsten, nee, nee. Hat mit dem ersten Teil, so wie ich das jetzt bisher gesagt habe, überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Es gibt bestimmt die ein oder anderen Referenzen auf den ersten Teil, ja. Aber ansonsten hat es nichts damit zu tun.
Oh, gebashed. Die werden jetzt richtig geklatscht.
Also, die Antwort ist doch relativ einfach, oder? Die Waffe ziehen und sie nieder machen. Was sonst?
Oh, die werden gebashed.
So, was machen wir denn jetzt?
Wir verwandeln uns erstmal.
Und jetzt rennen wir so um. So muss das sein. Bam.
Ah, okay.
Stimmt, das ist jetzt erneut im zweiten Teil. Es gibt jetzt ja Schilde.
Also sprich, das, über dem Namen, das Graue ist quasi Rüstung und das Blaue ist sowas wie Mana, glaube ich.
Aber der Typ, der hält nicht mehr viel aus. Da hauen wir jetzt einfach drauf und dann ist er down.
Oder wir werfen unser Schild viel besser. Bam.
Der kann ja nichts.
Jetzt machen wir erstmal seine Rüstung kaputt. Oder wir können uns auch wieder Schild geben.
Gucken wir mal, wir machen jetzt erstmal seine Rüstung kaputt.
Noobzwerg. Was ist denn das?
Turn in der Nähe, Target to Stone.
Also ich würde sagen, wir turnen jetzt mal in der Nähe, Target to Stone. Was sagt ihr dazu?
Machen wir das jetzt mal in der Nähe, Target to Stone. Wobei, nee, nee, nee, das geht jetzt nicht, weil der hat Mana noch übrig.
Das heißt, der kann das blocken. Wir hauen jetzt einfach drauf.
Ach, der macht keinen Damage, der kann nichts. Naja, wobei.
Bam, zack. Da geht er down.
Jetzt probieren wir mal was. Wir legen uns jetzt einfach, wir legen uns jetzt einmal schlafen. Easy.
Ja, kein Ding. Kurz, kurze Runde, kurz Nickerchen gemacht.
Doch, kein Problem. Schiff ist kurz vor dem Untergehen. Wir machen Nickerchen wieder voller Leben. Easy. So geht das. Wie in echt.
Alles grabben. Briefe, alles grabben.
Das einzige, wo wir gucken müssen, später ist, also wir lesen das natürlich nicht. Das ist zu...
Wer liest schon Quests außer der Kasten?
Lull. Wir müssen bloß Crafting-Bücher lesen.
Alles einpacken. Im Zweifelsfall können wir das später verkaufen.
Ohne Schatzkiste. Nice.
Na, das ist aber schlechter als...
Gut, wahrscheinlich, wenn ich jetzt... Oh, wie hieß es in der deutschen Übersetzung, wenn ich jetzt Spitzbube wäre,
dann könnte ich wahrscheinlich hier mit Dual-Wheel-Dollchen rumrennen.
So, erstmal hinlegen. Easy. Schiff geht unter. Haupt kein Problem.
Weiter geht's. Ach nee, hier komm ich ja nicht raus.
Oh, das hört sich nicht gut an. Hauptsache der Hund ist nass.
Looten. Nix drin. Looten. Nix drin.
Bester Item-Name. Mein erster Bogen.
Anubis, bevor ich Quests lese, guck ich Guide. Ich hasse Quests lesen.
Ich hab wahrscheinlich im ersten Teil kaum Quests gelesen.
Haben wir das schon gelootert? Ja.
Looten. Abel. Looten. Feuer ausmachen. Looten.
Oh! Das ist wa... Nee, das... Das ist wahrscheinlich eher der Schlüssel für hier.
Guck mal, wer da sitzt. Der Typ von eben.
Würde ich auch machen, wenn das Schiff untergeht. Wobei, der ist schon untot.
Hab ich mal ein Glas hingestellt.
Ich bin Piratenzwerg. Ich runne und screame nicht, wenn ich aufm Schiff bin.
Wo kommen wir denn dahin? Die And... Okay.
Mein Held hat noch nicht gemerkt, dass das der gleiche Typ von eben ist.
Obwohl er... Naja, gut. Er kann dann auch nicht den Mauszeig drüber ziehen.
Hm. Der Typ kommt mir irgendwie vertraut vor.
Das ist der Elf, der das Buch gelesen hat. Nein! Wer hätte das gedacht.
Okay, das war nur eine Maske, dass er elf war.
Siehste, jetzt krieg ich sogar Sympathie-Pointe. Wobei ich eigentlich mit Fane gar nicht spielen will.
Also ich hab mir das im Vorfeld mal überlegt. Ich werd wahrscheinlich ne Party basteln aus dem Zwerg.
Der Baden, diesem Armbrusttyp, der oben an der Tür gestanden hat. Und als wir das mal gucken.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich der Elfin-Rogue. Elfin-Spitzbubin auf Deutschland.
Mit der wir übrigens gar nicht geredet haben, oben fällt mir ein. Die stand da rum. Hab ich irgendwie nicht mitgekriegt.
Looten. Looten. Wichtig. Alles looten. Gold. Looten.
Kann man hier noch looten? Ahoi.
So viel zu looten und nirgendwo was drin.
Nirgendwo was drin. Aber in die Mitte gehen wir jetzt noch mal. Machen das mal auf.
Schlüssel.
Nein, nein, nein. Wir gehen hier nicht raus. Wir looten erst mal.
Schwert. Oh Schwert. Schwert ist schön. Endlich mal ne ordentliche Waffe.
Oder auch nicht. Kann ich den hier looten ohne zu verrecken? Ja sehr schön. Easy. Gehen wir mal raus.
Anubis, ich hab den Baden. Du hast die Baden, den Roten Prinz und den Untoten. Ich muss mal gucken. Aber ich glaube, wie gesagt, ich nehm die Baden und den Armbrust Typ.
In your face. So, jetzt verwende ich Aktionspunkte um zu looten. Nee, glaube ich eher nicht. Ich werd erst mal die Gegner bashen.
So. Eine schleimige leere Kreatur. Die schleimige leere Kreatur soll mal zu mir kommen. Ich hab Rüstung. Rüstung ist voll.
Naja, ich könnte mal ein Schild werfen. Oder verwandle ich mich? Ich könnte mich auch verwandeln. Ich verwandel mich mal. Das schadet auf jeden Fall nichts.
Guck mal hier, ich hab sogar Hörner. Seht ihr das hier? Hörner aus meinem Helm raus. Und nun, nein wir rennen nicht die Gegner um. Wir werfen erst mal unser Schild.
Jetzt machen die mich schonmal ordentlich Damage. Und das machen wir jetzt auch nicht. Wir warten. Die sollen einfach mal rankommen. Ich spar mir einfach meine Punkte.
Evade. Guck mal, der ist vergiftet. Jetzt können wir sie umhauen. Die haben auch keine Rüstung mehr. Das geht. Get Shreked.
Nun, ja nun hauen wir einfach drauf. Und sobald die aufstehen, rennen wir sie um. Mit unseren Hörnern. Aber der ist jetzt down.
Jetzt rennen wir ihnen nochmal um. Was Ziel ist blockiert? Durch was ist denn das Ziel blockiert? Bam. Get Shreked. Haben die Looter dabei? Nope.
Feuerball Schriftrolle. Man kann bestimmt aus Schriftrollen Bücher craften. Müssen wir mal gucken wo man später Crafting Rezepte herkriegen. Nicht durch das Gift rennen.
Der hat nichts. Nicht durch das Gift rennen. So hätten wir jetzt dieses Talent genommen, dass man sich in Blut heilt, könnte man sich hier heilen. Aber die Gegner können nichts. Ich habe immer noch voller Leben. Jetzt ist ja auch noch Tutorial.
Die müssen gelootet werden.
Die müssen gelootet werden. Wie komme ich denn jetzt am besten hin? Wasserfass? Wasserfass. Moment. Wir löschen jetzt mal kurz das Feuer. Easy.
Wir löschen mal kurz das Feuer, das ich looten kann. Das ist jetzt wichtig. Das ist wichtiger als vom Schiff zu fliehen. Looten hat Vorrang. Nein, nein, nein. Was? Ich will das. Ey, was ist das?
Ist das hier eklig? So, rauf hier. Weil von der anderen Seite wäre besser gewesen, oder? Egal, wir rennen da jetzt durch. Easy. Guck mal, das war überhaupt kein Ding. Jetzt kann gelootet werden.
Für vier Gold. Zauberstrahl. Der bringt bestimmt Kohle später.
Rettungsbord. Ist hier unten irgendwas? Hier kann man runterklettern, aber hier gibt es...
Das sehe ich auch so. Wir müssen hier weg. Aber ich meine, wir sind der Held. Außerdem waren wir früher Pirat. Wir kennen uns auf dem Schiff aus. Und wir lassen keine Leute zurück. Wir sind ja doch irgendwo der Gute, ne? Schisser.
Ich mache das jetzt alleine. Ich gehe jetzt runter und rette alle. Gibt es noch was zu looten? Eigentlich will ich nicht die Leute retten, sondern sie looten.
Oh, die habe ich ja noch gar nicht gelootet. Das geht ja nicht. Moment. Was habe ich da gerade gelootet? Was war das?
Nope. Wenn ich jetzt elf wäre, weil Elfen sind Fleischfresser und Cannibalen in diesem Universum, dann könnte ich jetzt wahrscheinlich...
Also wenn man als elf irgendwelche Teile von Leuten frisst in diesem Game, dann kriegt man Teile von ihrer Erinnerung und so was. Kriegt neue Skills und Zeug.
Also was lernen wir da raus? Esst Menschen, wenn ihr schlauer werden wollt.
Jetzt, wenn der Typ jetzt quasi da rum liegt, kann ich das Buch crammen.
Gehen wir mal den anderen helfen.
Wo haben wir da einen Gegner? Da ist ein Gegner, da ist ein Gegner. Das sind die NPCs. Das habe ich ja alles noch gar nicht gelootet. Ohje.
Schweres Versäumnis.
Vermandeln wir uns.
Und rennen den Gegner um.
Bam. Wobei rennt das überhaupt den Gegner um? Macht das überhaupt?
Einfach mal drauf fahren. Zack.
Oh und nicht verrecken.
WP-Sebaro.
Mit der haben wir vorher nicht geredet.
Die soll übelst OP sein, habe ich gelesen.
Also generell Rogue mit den passenden Talenten soll absolut OP sein.
Oh das Ding ist verreckt.
Wie der Gegner schockiert ist. Ja Hunter. Ist halt noch Beta Übersetzung. Mein Zug.
So eigentlich haben die schon alle Gegner geschreckt ohne mein Zutun. Deswegen kann ich jetzt, ich haue einfach mal drauf.
Aber vielleicht ohne den anderen zu hitten.
Also die gleichen NPCs die man hier oben sieht kriege ich auch später in meiner Party dann.
Da geht er down.
Kille die sich jetzt selbst oder wie?
Ja Sebaro das sind ein paar Gegner mehr zum Bashen aber ich habe ja auch NPCs die Bashen schon alle.
So.
Wir können nicht fliehen. Das geht nicht. Wir müssen looten.
Ich fliehe gleich. Leute ich komme gleich nach. Ich muss erst mal looten.
Erst mal looten.
Ne die NPCs sind später auch Level 1 und Level 2.
Die haben auch nicht die Fähigkeiten wie man sie hier eben gesehen hat. Man kann nicht später skillen wie man will.
Anscheinend haben die einfach jetzt irgendwelche random Fähigkeiten gekriegt dass sie halt hier kämpfen konnten.
So gibt es sonst noch was zu looten?
Gehen wir mal. Ah nee Moment. Doch gehen wir.
Oh der wird gebashed. Moment ich speichere mal kurz.
Ich will mal gucken ob das geht.
Die braucht keine Hilfe die muss gebashed werden.
Ich lade noch mal. Ich wollte noch gucken was sie zu sagen hat. Ich wollte nur gucken ob das funktioniert dass man die bashen kann.
Maxi Sieben du kannst dir den Stream als Wort angucken. Ich habe alle Streams als Wort.
Also ich habe das so eingestellt dass das alles speichert. Sie versucht zu sprechen.
Ich will ihr nicht helfen.
Okay sind wir mal nett. Wir tun mal so als wollen wir ihr helfen.
Eigentlich will ich die nicht retten.
Ist das Spiel etwa so wie ein Pen and Paper? Ja ähnlich. Im Multiplayer auf jeden Fall.
Wenn man dann vielleicht noch ein paar Leute hat die ein bisschen RPGen wollen.
Aber es ist eindeutig so an den alten isometrischen RPGs so wie Baldur's Gate orientiert. War auch der erste Teil schon.
Scheiß drauf wir machen jetzt kalt.
Luten. Erstmal luten.
Ich sehe es in nicht ein warum ich die retten sollte. Was hätte ich für einen Grund zu retten?
Ich bin Piratenzwerg der gefangen genommen wurde. Warum sollte ich den Typen die mich gefangen genommen haben retten?
So gehen wir raus.
Ich kenne das Spiel.
Ladezeit.
Ich bin nass.
Mein Hut.
Das geht ja nicht.
Na gut wenn man Hut weg ist muss ich erstmal. Oh ich habe eine Donation gekriegt. Maxi sieben Donate. 10 Euro seit den Black Ops 1 Zeiten.
Danke für die Donation. Vielleicht gibt es am nächstes auch einen Subbutton. Aber ich habe noch keine konkreten Pläne.
Aber danke für die 10 Euro. Und vielleicht ist ja das neue Call of Duty so gut dass ich es auch wieder spiele. Dass ich mich sehen nicht wirklich was.
Das ist der Typ aus dem ersten Teil. Der war schwer im ersten Teil.
Die Beta soll bald starten. Ja habe ich gelesen. Es gibt sogar PC Beta zum neuen Call of Duty.
29. oder so. Wie viel haben wir heute? 17? Na okay das dauert noch ein bisschen. Moment 29.
Das bedeutet doch das ist quasi eine Woche vor Release. Dann ist es keine Beta. Dann ist es wieder so ein Promotion Ding.
Reden wir mal mit Tam. Tam? Tam war das nicht mal ein CS Clan? So vor 20 Jahren oder so?
Ich glaube Tam war mal ein CS Clan. Aber das ist schon so was von überholt. Man kann übrigens fast mit jedem NPC trainen.
Ich versuche gerade den Chat zu checken was zu viel Schiffs kann. Ach so Assassin's Creed Black Flag. Das hat funktioniert.
Also das Game lief finde ich ziemlich gut. Mir ist es gar nicht aufgefallen dass es einen 60 FPS Log hat. Hat aber Spaß gemacht. Also von allen Assassin's Creed in letzter Zeit fand ich Black Flag eigentlich am besten.
Von den letzten paar. Hat er irgendwas zum handeln? Was? Ich soll 300 Gold ausgeben für sowas? Ne. Das machen wir bestimmt nicht.
Ja. Das ist schön. Ich will mit dir auch nicht reden. Genau. Mit komischen Kindern will ich auch nicht reden.
Und außerdem der Game hat vollkommen recht und außerdem sieht das menschliche Auge ja eh nur 24 Bilder pro Sekunde. Da ist das doch überhaupt kein Unterschied.
Danke. Hab bestimmt recht.
Er stimmt halt auch so ein Halsring.
Soll ich jetzt nicht weiter?
Genau. Wenn man auf einem Auge blind ist sieht man nur 12 FPS. So ist es. Endlich mal jemand der es verstanden hat.
Moment kann man das? Das sieht aus wie eine Schatzkiste die man looten kann. Aber es ist doch nur ein was auch immer. Was mit matschiger Textur drauf.
Moment. Hier gibt es angeblich einen Schnellreisepunkt. Den habe ich doch schon oder? Ja ja den habe ich schon.
Gibt es hier irgendwelche Sachen versteckt? Oh es hat gespeichert. Das heißt jetzt passiert irgendwas.
Die werden jetzt gebashed. Wie machen wir das jetzt am besten? Lass es mal überlegen. Wie können wir die jetzt am besten schrecken?
Granate.
Oh nee die haben mich gesehen. Ist ja dumm. Ich würde sagen den hauen wir. Ah Mist das ist ja doof. Kann ich?
Kann ich da hin laufen und dann die Typen umwerfen? Ach fuck das reicht nicht. Scheiße. Kann ich die um. Aber ich kann die umrennen.
Dann renne ich den jetzt um. Bam. Und jetzt habe ich keine Energie mehr. Hauptsache die treffen nichts. Oh das haben sie mich aber ganz schön hier in die Zeige genommen.
Jetzt können wir sie aber umhauen. Bam. Werfen wir unser Schild noch. Dann kriegen beide Damage.
Die sind fast down. So muss das sein. Nächsten Zug können sie nicht nehmen weil sie nieder geschlagen sind. Und der auch. Bam. So muss das sein.
Level Up. Yeah. Aber erstmal looten. Jetzt schreckt. Genau. Ist ja noch was. So Level Up.
Ich muss unbedingt mein Helm wieder finden.
Was skillen wir denn jetzt? Skillen wir überhaupt was oder heben wir uns das erstmal auf?
Also wenn ich das richtig verstehe. Polymorph bringt ja einmal dass ich hier diese Gestaltenwandler Fähigkeiten einsetzen kann.
Plus dazu kriege ich von jedem Punkt in Polymorph nochmal einen zusätzlichen Attributpunkt. Was eigentlich ziemlich gut ist wenn man sich das mal überlegt.
Aber wir skillen erstmal eine Runde Tank Speck hier. Also Mele Nachkampf Speck.
Also ich würde mal vermuten dass das beste Verhältnis. Also ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich habe das Game nicht weit gespielt.
Ich vermute mal das beste Verhältnis dürfte sein. Sagen wir so zwei Drittel ein Drittel.
Und spezialisierte Sachen wie einhändiger Kampf oder zweihändig oder Dual Wield würde ich erst Richtung End Games becken. Weil damit legt man sich ja, also das ist jetzt so allgemein so RPG übergreifend irgendwie für alles gültig finde ich.
Ich lege mich bei solchen Games immer erst relativ spät auf eine gewisse Waffenkategorie fest. Weil man weiß ja nicht was man für Waffen findet.
Das heißt wenn ich jetzt hier beispielsweise schon einhändig Schild specke und ich finde jetzt die ultra geile Zweihandwaffe ärgere ich mich weil ich einhands Schild gespeckt habe. Dann specke ich doch lieber erstmal weiter meine Nachkampfspecke die einfach für alles mehr Damage gibt.
Und ab und zu machen wir noch ein bisschen weiter Polymorph. Da können wir uns mehr Gestaltenweichlerfähigkeit kaufen und kriegen noch mehr Punkte. Das klingt gut.
Hallo Kupa 4500, ich muss gerade mal was gucken. Danke für die Follows. Jetzt lädt leider gerade Streamlabs. Und was backen wir jetzt noch? Schleichen specken wir nicht.
Überreden können wir specken. Das haben sie besser gemacht als im ersten Teil. Im ersten Teil waren das hier soweit ich weiß alles noch die gleichen Skillpunkte.
Und das hatte das Problem dass du quasi entscheiden musstest. Machst du deinen Held kämpferisch besser oder irgendwie so Life Skill mäßig. Was dazu geführt hat dass eigentlich kaum einer dieses Zeug geskillt hat.
Überreden. Ich specke überreden. Überreden ist gut. Kann man bestimmt nichts verkehrt machen mit.
Das ist eh gut wenn ich das mit meinem Hauptcharakter mache weil da muss ich nicht switchen. Die NPCs reagieren ja drauf mit welchem Charakter man sie anspricht.
Aber wenn mein Hauptcharakter den ich hauptsächlich steuer das höchste Ansehen hat ist ja gut. Da muss ich nicht switchen vorher.
So und jetzt specken wir mal. Also Leben habe ich genug finde ich. Ich specke jetzt Stärke. Mit Damage. Mit Damage machen.
Aber Ackle. Der Frosch ist da. So weiter gehts.
Es ging im ersten Teil eigentlich auch die Kamera zu drehen. Das frage ich mich die ganze Zeit schon.
Kann ich mich nicht daran erinnern dass ich das ausgiebig gemacht habe im ersten Teil.
Skill. Tod durchs Schwert. Waffenkunde. Danke für den Follow.
Tis Lijar.
Ok.
Ja. Obzatz. Ich kann mir konnte mich da nicht mal dran erinnern. So das ist ein Crafting Buch. Das heißt. Wo ist es denn?
Befestige dein Messer an einem Stock. Ja sowas habe ich doch eh schon an.
So und dann kriegt man Crafting Rezepte.
Messer am Stock kann ich bauen. Super.
Bringst mir aber nicht weil ich hab schon ein Messer am Stock.
Gehen wir mal weiter. Mal den ganzen Mist hier einsammeln.
Ach guck mal wer da ist. Aber erstmal looten. Hallo Bela Rack. Aber erstmal looten.
Also bevor wir hier irgendwie mit NPCs reden wird erstmal gelootet.
Kann man bestimmt verkaufen später. Gibt ein bisschen Kohle.
Außerdem hat man in dem Game eh ein letztliches Inventar wie man hier sieht.
Bloß beschränkt durch meine maximale Stärke. Deswegen ist das richtig gut.
Ich weiß im Nachhinein aus das war sogar relativ clever dass ich gesagt habe ich spiele hier als Hauptcharakter einen stärkebasierten Held.
Der auch noch gut mit Leuten reden kann. Das ist top. Da muss ich weniger Helden switchen.
So reden wir mal mit ihm.
Also wie gesagt mein Plan ist als Party Zusammenstellung später.
Die Baden zu haben, den Rogue und den Armbrust Typ.
Also ihnen nehme ich jetzt nur mal temporär mit.
Weiß jemand ob es Respec gibt? Kann man Respecken? Im ersten Teil ging das nach einer Weile.
Ich vermute das es hier auch geht.
Ja? Okay super.
Ich vermute mal er kann besser schwimmen als ich wenn ich mir ihn so angucke.
Ich bin Piratenzwerg. Ich bin nicht freundlich.
Na komm wir müssen ja nicht komplett zur Sau machen gleich. Wir sind für Mannett zu ihm.
Der Voice Actor bringt es aber das Überhebliche schon gut drüber von dem Typ.
Ich tendiere ja zu dem. Dann ist er wahrscheinlich stinkig auf mich aber das passt einfach zu dem Held mehr.
Du bist mir schon etwas mehr schuldig.
Mir fällt gerade auf, ich spiele ja Zwerg. Da kann ich ein bisschen üben für meine nächste Dungeons & Dragons Runde.
Da spiele ich einen Zwerg Clary und ich tue mir noch schwer Zwerge zu roleplayen.
Ja warum er hier rum steht ist mir eigentlich ziemlich wurscht.
Ihn fragen was er als nächstes vor hat.
Bist du nicht klein und dick in der L? Weinst du da müsste ich das können?
Ich bin kein Zwerg und ich habe nicht so einen geilen Eimer auf dem Kopf.
Okay ich war Pirat das spricht mich natürlich persönlich an.
Nächstes Mal setze ich mir auch einen Eimer auf dem Kopf.
Ja komm weiter hier.
Ich fürchte wir werden ihm nicht helfen können sein Empire wieder zu erlangen.
Weil wir ihn nicht in einer Party mitnehmen. Zumindest so temporär erstmal.
Wissen wir wer er ist oder wissen wir es nicht?
Ja komm wir kennen ihn dann freut er sich bestimmt.
Oh find er sich geil.
Jawoll komm mit. Ihn einladen mit dir zu reisen.
Er kann gerne mitkommen.
Das wird sich einrichten lassen ich nehme dich eh nicht mit.
Ich behalte das im Hinterkopf.
Also ich habe ja eh nicht vor ihn mitzunehmen.
Aber zumindest temporär bis ich die anderen Partymember gefunden habe.
Ja was soll er denn werden? Ach der kann ruhig weiter Nahkämpfer bleiben das ist schon okay.
Ich meine ein Zauberer war auch nicht verkehrt.
Ich will auch noch die Baden und den Armbrust Typ dabei haben.
Egal er darf Kämpfer bleiben und wir spielen jetzt einfach mal bis wir die anderen gefunden haben mit zwei Nahkämpfern.
Oder wir fragen ihn ob er Zaubern können.
Ganz bestimmt, ganz bestimmt das kann er sich abschmelken.
Auf gehts. Moment habe ich noch einen Helm für dich?
Ich habe keinen Helm mehr das ist ja doof.
Okay der Typ ist Level 2. Was hat er für Skills? Kriegsführung und Geomat.
Okay und an Skills hat er ziemlich ähnlich zu meinem anderen Held bloß er hat hier noch einen Rüstungsbuff. Ach das ist schon okay erstmal.
Was hier oben? Hätte ich jetzt mal einen der mit Katzen reden kann.
Ich würde auch Confuse den Kopf schütteln wenn ich mich hier so sehen würde.
Kind vom Schiff. Muschel erstmal alles einsammeln. Alles einsammeln. Moment.
Ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl die Anzeige stimmt nicht so ganz.
Die Anzeige stimmt nicht so ganz wo diese Muschel ist.
Die ist vom Schiff. Anti1237 was hast du gehofft das dieses Kommando macht? Vielleicht kann ich es dir auch so sagen.
Was für ein PC ich habe? Oder was wolltest du mit dem Kommando? Okay das kann ich nicht aufheben.
Wie findest du die künstliche Entwicklung von Manny Boy? Ehrlich gesagt ziemlich beknackt.
Ich fand den Typ früher ultra lustig. Als man noch das Gefühl hatte er nimmt den Kram selbst nicht ernst.
Ich bin ihm auch bestimmt 1-2 Jahre auf Twitter gefolgt und wie gesagt fand er es ultra lustig was er für ein Scheiß geschrieben hat.
Aber mit der Zeit hast du gemerkt dass er den Kram selbst glaubt. Zumindest kommt es einem so vor.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht das Geschwätze muss ich mir nicht länger geben.
Okay wo geht es denn hier lang? Da ist ziemlich viel unentdeckt.
Wo kommt man da hin? Da ist eine Ranke.
Was? WTF?
Ich würde mal sagen mein Kletterskill reicht nicht aus. Ich weiß nicht wie ich das gerade interpretieren soll sonst.
Was hört ihr mal den neuen Track an von Manny Boy? Ich weiß nicht. Ich habe gerade nicht so Bock drauf.
Hier kann man bestimmt später hochfliegen, hochteleportieren und sonst was in der Richtung machen.
Wo geht es hier lang? Oh eine Kiste. Nice.
Nein ich werde jetzt bestimmt nicht auf gut Glück den neuen Manny Boy Track anmachen. Ach guck mal wer hier wieder ist. Schleinfass.
Den looten wir jetzt bevor wir mit dem reden. So easy. Alles weg looten.
Er hat es auch überlebt. Aber gut der ist ja schon tot.
Welche PC hast du? Also welche Grafikkarte? Prozessor und so.
Uralt also drei Jahre alt bis auf die Grafikkarte.
Grafikkarte ist ein 1080ti. Referenzdesign.
CPU ist ein Intel Xeon 1230V3 oder so. Ist schon eine Weile alt, würde ich mir jetzt so nicht kaufen.
Mainboard keine Ahnung aus dem Kopf. Aber der PC ist alt bis auf die Grafikkarte.
Okay der versucht eine neue Maske von dem Ding, von dieser verschimmelten Leiche hier abzuziehen.
Bring Skelette habe ich gelesen, haben als Rassenfähigkeit Schlösserknacken mit den Fingern. Braucht man keine Tiedriche.
Diese Echsen können buddeln ohne Schaufel und Zwerge keine Ahnung was Zwerge können.
Was treibst du da? Ach super Sebaro dass du es rausgesucht hast.
Steht in der Beschreibung. Ich bin überrascht ihn zu treffen.
Mich interessiert eher was er mit der Leiche vor hat.
Gesicht rausschneiden, was auch sonst.
Ich frage ihn ob er mitkommen will.
Ich will eigentlich nur fragen ob er mitkommt.
Es sieht ziemlich eternal aus.
Das klingt als würde er einen Begleiter brauchen.
Der darf Magier bleiben.
Zauberer ist top, er wird nämlich auch später ausgetauscht.
Könntest du wieder ein Hardware Video machen wo du bestimmte Rechner empfehlen könntest?
Zauberer ist hervorragend.
Er wird von Heal-Zauberbrüchen und Gift-Zauberbrüchen geheilt.
Das ist besser als mein Schild.
Wenn er durch das Schild durchläuft wird er geheilt.
Ihr dürft auch hoch gehen.
Es gibt wieder XP für Entdecken.
Ich kann mich nicht mit Hardware auskennen.
Ich kenne mich immer einmal aus wenn ich mir einen neuen Rechner kaufen muss.
Ich kenne auch drei, Spaß bei euch!
Sehr schön.
Next.
So, gibt's hier sonst noch irgendwas zum Crabben?
Gehen wir gleich mal hier runter.
Okay, das gehört alles diesen NPCs hier.
Das hebe ich jetzt nicht auf.
Was?
What the fuck?
Das betrifft mich nicht.
Vollkommen richtig.
Ich würde auch am liebsten wieder gehen.
Machen wir nicht.
Wir wollen was bashen.
Das darf man alles nicht aufnehmen.
Hallo CheesyPro36.
Aha.
Man kann nicht...
Ich dachte, ich muss...
Die muss ich bestimmt bashen.
Aber ich kann mit denen reden.
Aber ich hab keinen, der mit Tieren reden kann.
Irgendwie, ne?
Verspüre ich gerade den Drang dazu, die Gegner zu bashen.
Ich verspüre den Drang, das Viech hier anzugreifen und zu bashen.
Wow.
Oh oh.
Das ist scheiß Position.
Ich stehe jetzt ja mitten drinnen.
Vielleicht muss ich gleich nochmal laden und das ordentlich engagen.
Okay, mein Zauberer ist zuerst dran.
Okay, probieren wir den...
Macht das noch Knockdown?
Riesiger Felsen von bewirkt...
Weil das war im ersten Teil der absolute OP-Skill.
Dieser Felsbrocken.
Wir müssen den Gegner umwerfen.
Kostet 2 Punkte, kostet 2 Punkte.
Okay, wir burst...
Wir versuchen hier mal, den hier kaputt zu machen.
Bam.
Das castet irgendwas.
Eigentlich bin ich...
Nein, das Viech hat noch...
Das stirbt eh.
Das stirbt nächste Runde an Brenndamage.
Da muss ich nichts mehr machen.
Ah, nice.
Wir können den anfackeln.
Oh.
Oh, das war keine so gute Idee.
Ich hätte mir vielleicht mal die Spellbeschreibung durchlesen müssen.
Es brennt mein Zwerg.
Lull.
Werfen wir nochmal unser Schild.
Gott, der ist down.
Perfekt.
So, jetzt ist mein Zwerg dran.
Da chargten wir jetzt zu dem hier.
Vermandeln wir uns.
Und charg...
Können wir den rumchargen?
Geht das?
Oh, das bin ich mal gespannt.
Können wir den anscha...
Oder rennen wir jetzt gegen die Wand?
Nee, passt.
Bam.
Down ist er.
Und jetzt gehen wir noch aus dem Feuer raus, würde ich sagen.
Wir gehen nochmal aus dem Feuer raus.
Ja, eigentlich bleibt mir nur übrig, Damage drauf zu machen.
Und das macht sogar relativ gut Damage.
Was ist das denn?
Das ist doch ein Schild.
Oh, das ist ein Schild.
Das ist ein Schild.
Und das macht sogar relativ gut Damage.
Au.
Oh, WTF.
Das macht übelst Damage, das Ding.
Oh nee.
Mist.
Ja, das war scheiße.
Ich bin ja mitten in den...
Wir sind ja direkt um mich herum gespawnt.
Ähm, wir geben dem jetzt mal ein bisschen Rüstung.
Dass er nicht gleich down ist.
Bam.
Jetzt hauen wir drauf.
Ah, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Au, au, au, au, da macht er Damage.
Gut, dass ich dem eben Rüstung gegeben hab.
Der wär fast verreckt.
So, eigentlich sollten wir den jetzt mit dieser...
Eigentlich sollten wir den jetzt kaputt kriegen.
Ja, GG.
Hui, das war knapp.
Gut.
Ähm, warum dreht sich das?
Wisst ihr was, bevor wir looten...
Wo ist meine Schlafrolle?
Easy.
Zack, Leben wieder voll.
Nice.
Handschuhe.
Die kriegt...
Fane.
Top.
Haben wir sonst noch was?
Können wir das Zeug looten?
Bööö.
Äh, Fane?
Wo rennt der hin?
Durchdrengtes Tagebuch.
Okay, da gucken wir jetzt mal rein.
Das sieht für mich nämlich so aus, als gibt es eine Quest oder sowas.
Ist das eine Quest?
Nee, gibt keine Quest.
Dann lesen wir das auch nicht.
Nice.
Ah.
Okay, ich brauch eine Schaufel.
Das heißt, ich kann hier meinen Echsen-Typ nehmen zum Kramen.
Oh, Loot.
Gold. Gold ist immer gut.
Und auch eine ordentliche Menge Gold.
Den müssen wir noch looten.
Dieser was?
Dann, okay.
Gucken, was wir damit machen können.
Noch mehr Kisten.
Noch mehr Loot.
Ja, Zebaro hab ich gelesen heute Morgen.
Ah, Crafting.
Was?
Mal gucken, ob unser Skelett das mit seinen Fingern lockpicken kann.
Aber da hat er überhaupt keine Skill zum Schlösserknacken.
Ich glaub nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Nee.
Wisst ihr was?
Wir hauen einfach drauf.
Okay.
Mal aus dem Weg.
Wie viel Energie, wie viel hab ich denn da noch?
20 von 20.
Ach komm, damit kann ich die Kiste aufhauen.
Zack.
Okay, das dauert jetzt kurz.
Gleich ist meine Waffe im Arsch.
Aber ich hab ja noch ein bisschen was.
So, was gibt's hier?
Dolch, Schriftrolle, Gold, perfekt.
Easy.
Geh mal zurück.
Karsten, bist du eigentlich noch da?
Oh, jetzt hat er aber Gas gegeben.
Was hat's mit der Katze auf sich?
Die rennt doch da nicht ohne Spaß rum.
Oh, nicht verrecken Katze.
Katze, Katze, nicht verrecken.
Komm her Katze.
Katze, komm her.
Kann ich dich heilen?
Hab ich einen Heal?
Ich muss die Katze heilen.
Na wobei, die überlebt das bestimmt auch so.
Das kann ich nicht zulassen, dass der Katze was passiert.
Okay, die überlebt das auch so.
Weiter geht's.
Ja, Karsten.
Oh, nice, was ist das?
Ja, Karsten, wenn du da bist, wenn du willst, können wir später diese Remote-Gaming-Geschichte ausprobieren.
Buddel, Buddel, Buddel.
Oh, ein staubiger Beutel.
Nice.
Ich hab zwar keinen Burgen-Schütze, aber warum nicht?
Wem ziehen wir denn die Rüstung an?
Lederrüstung.
Lederrüstung kriegt mein Held.
Wobei hab ich irgendwelche Sachen?
Hemd?
Okay, gut, next.
Guck mal, ne Kiste.
Noch mehr Zeug, krass.
Richtig gute Starter-Ausrüstung, klar.
Die Katze ist immer noch halt, ich muss die Katze heilen.
Wie kann ich die Katze heilen?
Ich hab keine Heals, oder? Kann das sein?
Ich hab null Heals.
Hab ich vielleicht ne Schriftrolle, mit der ich heilen kann?
Ach, der passiert schon nichts.
Okay.
Okay, hier waren wir schon.
Da sind mir ein bisschen viele NPCs.
Ich hab kein Bock, dass die mich angreifen.
War schon alles.
Danke für die ganzen Follows, ich guck grad mal rein.
Stimmt das?
Xixoplace und Tisliare.
Danke für die Follows.
Klettern wir mal rauf.
Jetzt krieg ich auch noch ne Spende.
Da f**k, muss ich gleich nochmal nachgucken.
Sie waren 15 Euro.
Ich hab doch das letzte Mal schon gesagt, Donate nicht so viel.
Erstmal wieder was, Donate, Sellout.
Ach ja, ich wollte ja noch was zum Thema Sellout sagen.
Danke für die 15 Euro.
Donations, wo seh ich denn jetzt?
Genau, ja stimmt, ich wollte ja was zu Sellout erzählen.
Ab Montag muss ich dann Alienware Sellout machen.
Und zumindest krieg ich am Montag wahrscheinlich den Vertrag und die Details.
Das heißt, ich werd euch dann bei jeder Hardverfrage sagen Alienware.
Karten spielen.
Ich will keine Karten spielen.
Du kriegst von mir keine Kohle.
Erzähl mir doch mal, was das für eine Gebühr sein soll.
Ich tendiere zur 4.
Die Inhaftierungsgebühr kann er sich in A schieben.
Genauso Baro, so machen wir das nächste Woche.
Ihr kriegt von mir keine Inhaftierungsgebühr.
Vor allem nicht ihr, ihr seid auch Inhaftierte.
Okay, werd ich jetzt zwar nicht mit gerechnet, dass man sich jetzt mit den Kloppen muss, aber da kann man nichts machen.
Muss gebashed werden, wo gebashed werden muss, muss gebashed werden.
Erst mal schön, der Mauszeiger spackt ein bisschen.
Erst mal schön ein Fels procken auf den Kopf.
Und jetzt anzünden.
Und schon ist er fast down.
Gut, das hat kein Friendly Fire, der Spell, das weiß ich.
Auch die Banken haben aber viele Lebenspunkte.
Moment, Deckel, Schnecke, Ralvo. Zum Teufel, warum heißt er Schnecke und sieht der R? Egal.
Wollen wir das mal nicht hinterfragen.
Hauen wir ihn mal um.
Ach fuck, da hat er ja noch Rüstung gehabt. Ohi Schnup. Da werfen wir jetzt gleich mal unser Schild hinterher.
Das hat schon Damage gemacht.
Ja, er dürfte ziemlich immun sein gegen so Zeug als Skelett. Verwandeln wir uns.
Okay, der hat nicht mehr viel Leben, den rennen wir jetzt über den Haufen. Bam.
Ein Schlag noch. Wie viel Damage mache ich? Wo sieht man das noch mal? Wie viel Damage mache ich?
Naja, das wird nicht ganz reichen, ihn zu ownen. Aber viele... Ah doch, mit dem Schild, mit dem Schild mache ich ihn platt.
Zack.
Der Typ kriegt es aber dicke gerade.
Ich sehe die Gegner nicht. Ziemlich sackt.
Och Fane, kannst du nicht mal ordentlich laufen?
Ich würde sagen, wir machen jetzt erst mal Deckel kaputt.
Und Gegner im Umkreis entzünden. Das kann auch nie verkehrt sein. Bam.
Stimmt, die hat auf Gift gestanden, ist explodiert. Perfekt.
Okay, der sollte hier mal rausgehen jetzt.
Vier AP reicht genau, einmal drauf zu hauen. Fast down. Ist eigentlich nur noch der Typ übrig.
Nahkampfdamage bringt nichts.
Jetzt wollen wir den Deckel erst mal kaputt. Ah Mist. Ich dachte, wir können ihn umwerfen. Hauen wir den erst mal kaputt.
Zack, noch mal drauf. Jawoll.
Hauner frisst ordentlich Damage. Ich habe genug Rüstung. Das war's. Jetzt schrägt.
Speichern. Jetzt das Wichtigste, erst mal übernachten. Da ist mal wieder... Moment, ich kann jetzt einfach hier unten mal klicken.
Zack, voller Leben. Geht das auf Hardcore aus?
Oder wenn man auf einem höheren Schwierigkeitsgrad spielt? Weil das ist schon ganz schön OP, wenn man einfach übernachten kann nach jedem Kampf, wo man wieder volle Leben hat.
Ich hoffe jetzt ja mal, ich habe mir jetzt Storytechnisch nichts verbaut, weil ich die Typen abgemurkst habe.
Heiltrank, Teller. Granate, Eimer. Wir holen das jetzt.
Zack, perfekt. Fischgräten, also Kack muss ich nicht mitnehmen.
Haben wir alles gelootet? Ach nee, Schnecke, Schnecke müssen wir noch looten. Die Schnecke, oh krass. Nice. Die Schnecke.
Wie ist das für ein Zwerg gehört, mit Axt, so ist das gut.
Looten.
Diese Ringe um deinen Hals erinnern... Warte mal, jetzt steht mein Mikrofon... Super, ich habe mein Mikrofon jetzt genauso platziert, dass ich den ersten Teil von deiner Message lesen kann und den zweiten Teil nicht.
Diese Ringe um deinen Hals erinnern... Warte mal, jetzt steht mein Mikrofon jetzt genauso platziert, dass ich den ersten Teil von deiner Message lesen kann und den zweiten Teil nicht.
Als ob sie kaum atmen kann
Lass mich nicht touchen! Du bist zu nahe!
Diese Farbe, dieses Ort, die mein Leben ausdrückt! Ich kann nicht! Ich kann nicht!
Wie ist das möglich? Einen Moment bist du im Garten in der Sonne, den nächsten bist du hier und sie legen das Ding um deinen Nacken!
Seine Hände wechseln wieder zu ihrem Nacken. Sie versucht, sich zwischen ihrem Nacken umzudrücken.
Ein Zwerg!
Du bist zu nahe! Ich kann nicht! Ich kann nicht!
Ich habe sie vor drei Tagen hier gesehen. Sie war mit ihrem kleinen Hund spielen. Und ich war mit ihrem kleinen Hund spielen.
Hier, du sollst sie mit dir holen. Wenn du sie findest, gib ihr ihr das Ding und sag ihr ihr.
Sie verbringt sich einen stabilen Sturm von Tieren. Sie sollte dann mit dir kommen. Sie sollte dich zurückholen.
Ich gebe mein Bestes. So als Piratenzwerg ist es total leicht, die Übung irgendwie für die Kinder zu retten.
Kann man sich vielleicht das Quest-Item nochmal angucken?
Nee, aber man kann es verkaufen. Das ist vielleicht nicht so taktisch geschickt.
So, jetzt brauche ich erstmal meine anderen Party-Mitglieder.
Du bist zu nahe! Ich kann nicht! Ich kann nicht!
Soll ich sie mit dir holen?
Ich kann nicht!
psychol...psych...psychological
ne ne ab sellout ab montag ist Alienware
sellout angesagt
ab montag werde ich dann auf jede frage
was sich einer für Hardware kaufen soll werde ich sagen Alienware
am besten über meinen Reflink Alienware
ego...ne keine ahnung
ok
weiter gehts muss man die anderen party mitglieder finden
loot...aber erst mal looten...wichtigste
Tomatensauce...ja endlich hab ich da drauf gewartet
craft...crafting Rezept...klein mal reinschauen
neues Rezept
Messer am Stock...Bietzeug...ganz ein Biss da
wir können jetzt schon sellout machen...stimmt
ja aus dem bau da müssen wir unbedingt Alienware noch reinschreiben dann am montag
nix drin...Pilze
was willst du
wenn man was tun will wird einfach gebashed...ist doch ganz einfach
guck mal hier...wenn er frech wird machst du faxen mal richtig platt mit axen
wer sich noch an diese lyrische Meisterleistung erinnern kann
er wirkt etwas nervös
was hat er denn vor
eher nicht
nur einen sollte ich die restlichen Leute hier lassen oder was
ja eigentlich vielleicht ist er auch Spion
das machen wir nicht
moment ok das ist eigentlich egal wie oft ich das mache der fragt mich immer wieder das gleiche wir handeln mal mit ihm mal gucken was er hat
nichts gescheiters
ok also wir verbauen uns hier auch nichts am an absagen das ist gut
genau
mein lieblingslied richtig
wo sind dann hier meine anderen Mitstreiter jetzt
wo sind meine anderen Partymember
da ist lose die will ich haben lose komm her
sammeln wir erstmal lose ein
da muss jetzt ane wir sind ok wir haben noch platz aber wenn wir dann ifa nehmen dann müssen wir hier ihn wieder rausschmeißen aber vorher items entfernen
ich mache jetzt kein haftbefehl an
das ist jetzt zu viel
so sieht es aus
ich bin ins wasser gefallen
ich habe versucht zum boot zu laufen
was ich gehört habe
woodface
ich sehe der chat erfreut sich gerade an haftbefehl lyrics
eigentlich das will ich gar nicht so genau wissen ich will dass er mitkommt
wir sind mal nett
wieso ist oben recht so ein pleuer weil die grafik engine das für richtig
ich habe da nichts drüber gelegt oder so das soll so sein da geht es den da geht es den berg runter und die grafik engine meint das muss gepilot sein
ja auf kommet wo kann ich denn hier sagen party party angebot
das klingt nach einer super idee
was interessiert mich ob die von irgendwelche dämonen heim gesucht wird oder sonst was im zweifelsfall wird sie gepascht das einzige was der piratenzwerg kann kann alles besten was über den weg kommt
die darf genau das bleiben was das game vorschlägt ja entschanter das ist eine super kombination
ich weiß immer mal nicht dass ich mich jetzt irgendwie verdrücke weil dann kann sie heilen elektroschocks verteilen und feuerlöschen das ist wichtig das braucht man
auf gehts so
was hat sie denn geskillt
das ist gut dann werden wir jetzt mal fein sein zeug ausziehen und das kriegt lose an
okay ist gut ist gut fein ich ziehe wieder was ist das das wieder was anziehen
ist ja doch keine probleme damit was anzuziehen was ihnen skelettfeuer anhatte
ja so ist das gut
wie findest du das spiel bisher super ist wie der erste teil bloß ich habe das gefühl dass sie ein bisschen mehr wert auf story legen weil die story war im ersten teil wirklich kacke
ist ja nicht ein bisschen weit weg
moment ich glaube das ist das skript ist verbuckt ich sehe nichts ach eher ich dachte der andere typ der unten sollte jetzt hierher laufen weil das wäre irgendwie sinnvoll
ein bisschen weit weg ne aber hauptsache wir haben eine einmal auf dem kopf ich halte mich nicht raus ich weiß jetzt gebäscht
ich helfe ihr fahren kann ich den basten jetzt
der will sich nicht basten lassen
jetzt gibt es aber viele punkte
vorher wollen wir noch ifan rekrutieren
wir rekrutieren jetzt ifan und werfen fein wieder raus
will ich wissen was er vor hat
okay das heißt er will irgendwelche leute umbringen
kann er machen ist mir egal
so
du sollst
im prinzip will ich dass ifan genau das bleibt was er ist nämlich ein typ mit armbrust
ach fuck jetzt muss ich erstmal fein rauskicken
jetzt können wir ifan rekrutieren
moment muss ich den ganzen dialog jetzt nochmal machen
okay gucken wir mal was wir ifans becken können
was braucht man denn intelligenz braucht man wirklich intelligenz
was braucht man intelligenz intelligenz erhöht den schaden den du mit intelligenzbasierten
ich glaube nicht dass das irgendwie ein intelligenzbasierter angriff ist
lassen wir erstmal können wir nachher immer noch skillen wenn wir nicht weiterkommen sollten
ich glaube fast jeder npc kommt irgendwie mit geomant
dann darf ifan mit hentai reden
mein held darf allgemein mit npcs reden und lose kennt sich mit sachen aus ja das ist
gut und der typ der kommt eh gleich raus
das sieht auch nach einer guten party zusammenstellung aus
mdg play hi max danke für die scoop app
ja du meinst das kommando zeilen ding muss erst mal kurz nach überlegen was für eine
scoop app das ist wirklich gut ja das ist echt praktisch
das ist nicht technik das ist dominik verneigt euch
weil es könnte auch technik sein wenn ich mir den so angucke haben wir irgendwas
mir ist das vollkommen egal was die gotter erzürnt hat
ich hoffe dass die gotter erzürnt sind
wo soll ich die katze hin wo ist die katze hin
die steht bestimmt da da okay was ist hier am tor los hallo angelus und morris
was hier los was ist hier los ich komme ganz unauffällig hier reingehe
der hammer das ist der obermacker hier der boss
mdg play schön chillig bei euch er ist ja auch chill stream heute am montag ist
sehr laut mal gucken ob am montag wirklich sehr laut ist ob das klappt weil
ich hatte schon öfter sachen wo es hieß ja am montag oder ja am dienstag oder ja
in diesem termin und dann kam erstmal nichts
der buchhalter ich glaube dallas meint er hier den bischof
stehe einfach nur dabei und gucke zu und die reden auch nicht mit mir auch
weil ich das auch am anfang gedacht habe die reden nicht mit mir sondern mit
magister atusa die muss gebäst werden die hat es schon ganz dick quasi hier oben
stehen die muss sowas von gebäst werden gleich
eigentlich will ich ja hier nur raus
ja dritte antwort scheint mir irgendwie am besten zu passen
die wird so gebäscht die hat bisschen viel leben um sie jetzt
zu beschen aber wenn ich noch ein paar läffel habe dann kriegt die richtig aus
maul
ich gehe mal davon aus dass bischof alexander und dallas der hammer die
bosse von dem erst vom ersten akzent weil die haben so viel leben die anderen
fischer nicht haustier des hammers so sieht also ein haustier aus weiter
ist gar nicht übel wenn man die kohle dafür hat sich einfach nur etwas
holen muss er holen möchte was funktioniert spricht dann nichts dagegen
ich wurde gerade hierhin teleportiert warum wahrscheinlich weil das spiel damit
gerechnet hat dass ich von hier komme und ich von hier die katze ist wieder da
jawohl endlich kann ich die katze wenigstens mal heilen moment hat die
keine hiel eigentlich sollte los in den hiel haben warum hat lose kein hiel was
das für kack ich brauche hiel und skill skills skills fertigkeit
wegen hagel lose warum hast du denn kein hiel was soll das denn da muss ich jetzt
erst mal suchen wer mir in diesem gefängnis hier schriftrollen für
hydrosoff verkauft nicht dass die katze uns abkratzt 5k für 9 pc es gibt auch
günstigere von allen wer als 5k pcs das ist aber dann auch nicht übel das ist
zwar also preisleistungsmäßig fährt man natürlich noch besser wenn man sich
dann eigene zusammenschraubt aber viele leute haben da einfach kein bock drauf
die wollen jedenfalls kaufen was funktioniert dafür sind die sachen von
eher nicht verkehrt so was hat die dabei ich brauche langsam aber sicher
echt mal in elf wie gesagt elfen sind kann die balen in dem gelben ich brauche
den elf und wenn ich den elf habe dann kann er das bein fottern und mir sagen
siehst du es geht sogar noch tutorial vom vom gelben gesagt das habe ich schon
längst gelesen
so katze was machst du da katze was machst du da
kann man mit den handeln haben die was was wenn was wenn du dir diesen schädel
ans hält was
was hat der typ
ja versuch mich doch zu bashen könnte auch nichts naja gut die haben die haben
nur so viel rüstung wie ich leben habe naja
je größer ein mann desto kleiner sein ego da gibt es bestimmt noch eine
nicht jugendfreie variante vom zwergenspruch
auch nicht der cleverste
ja ich weiß dass die dass die übersetzung noch nicht fertig ist
ich würde es auch normalerweise auf englisch spielen aber ich habe
extra für streben auf deutsch umgestellt haben mit dem typ schon
geredet
das ist der typ von freund reden wir mal mit dem vielleicht hat er
irgendwelche krassen items die haben ja alle nichts das lohnt sich ja überhaupt
nicht mit denen zu handeln
spiel doch mal ein n64 super nintendo spieler ich
ich denke dass die meisten super nintendo n64 spiele wurden doch schon rauf und
runter gespielt
stamm habe schon ganz schön viel kack mitgenommen und ich habe noch maßig
inventarplatz hier darf man nichts mitnehmen sonst ist es stinkig
reden wir mal mit der handeln
beschwören habe ich nicht als skill bringt mir nix
ich bin sofort wieder da ich muss mal kurz gucken dass ich was zu essen finde ich
bin aufgestanden vor drei stunden oder so oder vor dreieinhalb stunden
bin rechner gesetzt hab stream angemacht nichts gefuttert jetzt müssen wir was
holen ich hab übelsthunger gleich wieder da
mache ich irgendwie mal ein overlay oder so
der
Ich will bei dir nix kaufen, du hast nur Crap?
Du hast nur Crap?
Was soll ich davon kaufen?
Nur Crap, was will ich damit?
Du hast Crap, das bröde!
Ich ccave jetzt das Gold ab, ver pol Kleineodle
Es gibt kein Crap
Ich habe aber nix gebraucht
Irgendetwas, das aggressioniert
bestimmt mehr wenn ich dir ordentlich was abkaufe verrät sie mir was ring das
so nice den den den nehme ich den kauf ich wie teuer der scheiß ist aber
fünf lebenspunkte warum nicht warum ich kann man als tank gebrauchen
so was verkaufen wir hier dann jetzt mal was verkaufen wir hatten da noch
eine goldbecher vom schiff haben wir den hier noch wo ist der gold kelch oder was
was ist das ding überhaupt ist das ne kraft crafting zubehör oder was ist der
gold kelch normalerweise zutaten für crafting ok ich glaube das lasse ich so
finden wir auch wieder bei meinen brauchen hiervon verkaufen nichts die
schriftrollen kann ich verkaufen brauche ich innert
feile behalte ich hier für die armbrust giftflasche das kann verkaufen das brauche
ich nett granaten brauche ich nett jetzt schrift scrolls kann man kann man in
dem game aus schriftrollen bücher craften dann hebe ich mir nämlich die
schriftrollen besser auf das ging im ersten teil glaube ich glaube ich bin
mal ganz sicher die muscheln die sind auch voll von arsch das alles nix wert
aber hier der krempel kann ich verkaufen
wobei
das einhebe ich mir mal auf
so ein rest füllen wir mit gold auf spielzeug armbrust brauchen wir nicht
mehr hat ihr fahren auch noch eine
bogen brauche ich auch nicht ich frage mich ob man ob ich den den hut wieder
finde vom zwerg
kommen den rest füllen mit gold auf
so hat man das jetzt irgendwas gebracht das ich mir da gehandelt habe
moment da hatte ich jetzt nicht mal was davon dass ich bei der was gekauft habe
was das dafuck ok ist taug dieser ring überhaupt irgendwas den ich mir da
gekauft habe
naja eigentlich sagt ich habe für ich genug leben
skam arst skam arst aber richtig skam arst hat sie mich
lade ich jetzt weil das hat schon ordentlich kohle gekostet jetzt noch
ach scheiß drauf ich lasse es jetzt skam arst und wenn vom ruckel das game so
das game ruckelt was gehen jetzt ab
ruckel das game dafuck was jetzt los wenn ich habe 36 fps was sind hier los
gerade vorher hatte ich 170
oder leckte es einfach nur hier drinnen ich starte mal neu ich starte mal neu das
ist definitiv nicht normal
so ich starte das game neu moment das game möchte gerade ein patch laden
jetzt game muss das sein patch laden in 2k 17 da kann ich jetzt mal meine
frikadelle futtern taimo meatballs
nee einfach nur meatballs hat einer von euch schon taimo meatballs
zubereitet falls ihr überhaupt wisst wovon ich rede
ich starte das game gleich wieder sobald das patch fertig geladen hat
takachi oder takahachi ja gönn dir was ist fanden 2
jetzt müsste ich wieder 100 fps haben
naja doch es ist schon mal viel besser guckt mal von 30 auf 75
und hier draußen habe ich wahrscheinlich einfach mal 100 115 easy ok funktioniert
wieder alles reboot tut gut so was geht hier ab
kreppen nichts drin kreppen nichts drin kreppen nichts drin nichts drin wo soll
das noch hinführen genau spotten da drüber jetzt das hätte mich jetzt auch
gewundert damit hätte ich es nicht gerechnet
das sind wegpunkte das ist ein schnellreisesystem verstanden
danke für die follows dann haben wir hier haro 500 mio 123098 werner d96
das war es so wo geht es weiter schon lange nichts mehr gebasht
ok ich vermute mal wichtige npcs sind mit roten fahnen markiert das heißt
bei dem schmied wo wir gerade gewesen sind da geht noch was
butter toller name oh was hat die jägers mann fähigkeiten das ist was für
die fahnen das muss ich mir merken ok hiel hiel zwar nicht verkehrt
wer hätte jetzt mal mein geld nicht für so eine scheiße ausgegeben
frikadella
ich brauche mal skills von ifan brauche ich mal
fallspitzen nieder das hat er schon da aber kein da hat aber kein hiel
ich will mir für ifan wünsche ich will mir hielsberg kaufen weil ich ja für
lose noch kein hielsberg habe also mein ziel ist erstmal für losen in hielsberg
und für ifan in hielsberg das probieren wir jetzt mal
erste hilfe halt das ziel und heilt außerdem verhörwerte das das brauchen wir das
das wollen wir haben so jetzt haben wir natürlich viel zu wenig kohle aber den
ganzen krempel können wir verkaufen zauberstab brauche alles nett lose
verwendet ehe zwei händer
kann man sonst noch verkaufen hier schrift rollen können verkaufen schrift
rollen braucht man dafür irgendwelche speziellen ist das nur für bogen oder
ist das auch für
hm habe ich genug kohle ganz knapp
das können wir noch verkaufen ich glaube nicht dass es bringt aber auch
keine kohle den lieblingsbogen kann man eigentlich den lieblingsbogen den
ziehen wir wahrscheinlich erst mal ifan an
da kommen wir in die schrift rollen noch
die will ich aber eigentlich behalten die pfeile
crafting zutaten will ich verkaufe ich nur ungern
ok komm kauf mal erste hilfe für ifan
tiger tank 32 wie findest du das neue battlefield 1 dlc falls du es
gespielt hast ne habe ich nicht gespielt ich habe viel eins nicht mal gekauft
nach der beta und das wirklich als battlefield fan hat mich nicht überzeugt
so ifan kriegt jetzt erst die hilfe beigebracht
übrigens ich hätte das vielleicht mit ifan machen sollen weil hätte ich ein
bisschen weniger gold bezahlen müssen egal
wo habe ich es denn hier skillbuch sprich nicht mehr durch automatisch
sortieren gut skillbuch ifan ja pfeile noch mehr
sachen für dich näher bogen skills hat er 6 bis 7 6 bis 8 besser der bogen ist ein deutsch besser und
ifan ich speichere mann ich stets mich jetzt verklecke ifan lernt jetzt erste
hilfe effekter ist es nice und jetzt heilt ifan die katze
wo ist die katze so ist das schon jetzt gibt es der katze wieder gut
weiter gehts muss jetzt irgendwas beschen wir haben wieder zeit
bett ob wir richtig krass spiegel schrift schon ein oder zwei unterwegs
den job gerade angefangen von drei stunden oder zwei stunden oder so moment
da bleib hier da ist selbstdings hier da die will ich doch haben so wir sind wir
sind ganz furchtbar moment hier leute ganz unauffällig schleichen wir den jetzt
hinterher ihr seht mich nicht und wenn die schleicht dem auch hinterher oder kann
das sein was geht
die will ich auch in der party haben dafür muss leider der rote prinz dran glauben
ich weiß
ich hände her zu zwei also eins muss ich sagen auch wenn wir jetzt die deutsche
übersetzung spielen ich habe das original in englisch gespielt dass die
wünsche normalerweise auch in englisch spielen also was sich zwischen dem
ersten teil im zweiten teil deutlich verbessert hat ist die qualität der der
texte die im ersten teil war einfach nur doof auf lustig gemacht und das hier
ist jetzt echt ganz okay ich frage sie jetzt mal das zweite sie nimmt mich in
zwitt also wie wie nimmt sie mich ins das das würde ich gern mal sehen wie sie
mich ins schwitzkasten im und 2 meter 30 11 nimmt so einen kleinen dicken zwerg
mit helmen mit einmal auf dem kopf ins schwitzkasten das wird wirklich gerne
sehen wie das funktionieren soll
loll ich bin ein zwerg moment geht gleich weiter
die will ich nicht beschen die will ich für meine party haben
genau ich bin der piraten captain der als bester bekannt ist es macht bestimmt
eindruck
die katze ich vermute ja ich weiß es aber nicht ich vermute ja
das ist mir eigentlich vollkommen egal was sie da für sachen auf der wange
hat also wenn einer da sitzt mich im schwitzkasten hat und ein messer an
hals hält interessiere ich mich selten für die namen die der andere im gesicht
hat aber fragen wir so nah ja erzählen siebille
da bra vielleicht solltest du noch mal neu laden wenn die katze tot ist
mal wo ist deine katze gestorben licht dass ich da auch gleich rein
renner also ich weiß nicht ob man die katze brauche aber ich gehe mal davon aus ich
warte jetzt eigentlich nur drauf dass ich noch ein paar level kriege dass ich das
talent nehmen kann wo ich mit wo man mit tieren reden kann das kann dann kann
dann lose oder ifan kriegt das dann mal gucken
wahrscheinlich lose oder ich gibt es den oder ich gibt es dem hier ich gibt es
dem hier weil es ja eher aus der partikel
Wir haben uns gesehen. Und ich will das Subjekt mit ihm aufreißen.
Nein!
Sie fährt den Knopf in die Tiefe und klingelt.
In der Wahrheit. Es ist nicht egal, wer du wirklich bist.
Du hast mich gesehen, Mark, mein Geist. Du kannst ihn erwarten, ihn retten oder ihn töten, bevor ich meine Chance bekomme.
Das ist übrigens laut Guide, den ich gelesen habe, ist Sibylle, der mit Abstand OP-ste Charakter in dem ganzen Game.
Vor allem mit Executioner als Talent. Ist das wohl sowas von One-Man-Army und OP?
Das macht dich eine Leidenschaft. Das macht dich Knödelkopf.
Das ist das Beste. Du hast zwar schon das Messer halb meinem Hallensteck, aber komm doch mit, lass ein bisschen rumlaufen.
Die lachende Spur ist eine tolle Proposal.
Ha, wie lustig. Ich erinnere mich, dass ich diese Entspannung nicht gesehen habe. Ich war sicher, dass das schmerzvolle Begrüßen gleich beginnen würde.
Mach deinen Fall und mach es schnell. Warum sollte ich dich beteiligen?
Eskarte. Ha ha ha. Wie du mich schmerzt.
Die meisten der verabschiedeten Dienste hier würden sagen, dass so etwas unmöglich ist.
Ha, gut gespielt. Oh, kleine Knödelkopf. Was soll ich tun? Puschen? Oder holen?
Du weißt was? Heute ist ein sehr schöner Tag. Sonne und einfachen Wind. Ja, ich bin nicht sicher, dass der Wetter ihn retten wird.
Mit einem schmerzigen Fingernis schlägt sie den Knödel von deinem Hals und lacht, als ob sie dich gerade für einen Tee besitzt.
Sie hat das Messer nur fest an den Hals gehalten.
Lass uns unsere jeweiligen Rollen diskutieren. Schade, dass du mich in der Todeszeit viel mit Hiden Seek spielst. Also, welche Rolle möchtest du mir spielen? Als Rogue, meine Spitzbude.
Ich habe gesagt, ich brauche keine Waffe oder Magie. Also, die Wahl ist deine.
Ich habe gesagt, ich brauche keine Waffe oder Magie. Also, welche Rolle möchtest du mir spielen? Als Rogue, meine Spitzbude.
Also, welche Rolle möchtest du mir spielen? Als Rogue, meine Spitzbude.
Wo ist eigentlich die Katze? Wo ist die Katze?
Habt ihr gesehen, wo die Katze hin ist? Wo ist die Katze?
Wo ist denn die Katze hin? Nee.
Gucken wir gleich, wo die Katze hin ist. Was die Katze mag, Sibylle nicht?
Das heißt, wenn die Sibylle in der Partie abhaut, haut die Katze ab.
Ja, ja, Sibylle macht das. Ich kann mit Sibylle handeln?
Nee, ja, ich kann mit der Exe handeln, obwohl die schläft. Das scheint mir irgendwie ein bisschen unrealistisch.
Ja, Sibylle, rede mal mit ihr. Also Sentinel-909, also ist das wirklich so?
Also sprich, wenn ich Sibylle in der Partie habe, geht die Katze weg?
Sehe ich das richtig? Das ist aber drauf.
Wohlgemerkt, Sibylle sticht gerade die Exe ab, aber ich kann immer noch mit ihr handeln.
Also Griff kennen wir doch, das ist doch der Typ aus der Küche, oder?
Aber ich kann immer noch mit ihm handeln, das ist doch auch geil. Gut, dass ich nichts brauche von ihm.
Hi, Alkenas7734. Rekt, würde ich mal sagen dazu. Hardcore Rekt.
Ach, jetzt kriege ich den Graben alles, das ist doch auch gut. Ich habe zwar niemand, der Feuerzauber kann, aber das nehmen wir doch gerne.
Erstmal alles abgreifen hier. Bratpfanne, Einhandstreitkolben. Nee.
Ich muss mit Sibylle reden. Das haben wir alles Woe zu verdanken, dass NPCs Ausrufezeichen über dem Kopf haben, wenn sie was zu sagen haben.
Wobei das war in Warcraft 3 auch schon so.
Das juckt mir schlecht. Das will ich aber auch nicht sagen. Ich habe damit als Piratenzwerg relativ wenig Schmerzen.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Pluspunkte.
Hallo, Ice-T.
Ja, was ich gerade für ein Arbitrat verspüre, das kann ich sich gar nicht vorstellen. Ja, den suchen wir jetzt auf.
Haben meine anderen Mitstreiter irgendwas zu sagen?
Mehr gibt es nicht. So, mal gucken, dass wir die Katze wieder finden jetzt. Vielleicht die Katze aber weg, weil da unten ein Hund rumläuft.
Gibt es hier irgendwas? Irgendwas Spannendes?
Was? Nein, ich suche die Katze.
Wahrscheinlich muss ich das machen, sonst gibt es keine Quest. Okay, ist ja gut, bleib hier.
Ich verstehe. Jetzt sag mir, wie deine Geschichte endet.
Oh, Quest.
Was? Was will das Game von mir? Achso, ob ich mit ihm handeln will. Brauche ich irgendwas von? Nein, das brauchen wir alles nicht.
So viele NPCs, da brauche ich ja noch Stunden, bis ich hier durch bin.
Aber ich habe es euch schon angedroht, das ist Slow-Paced, das Game. War der erste Teil auch, und trotzdem hat der erste Teil übertrieben Bock gemacht.
Okay, der Typ ist down. Wo ist die Katze? Ich muss jetzt die Katze suchen.
Da geht sie in eine Höhle rein, da gehen wir gleich hin. Wo ist die Katze?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die Katze hin ist. Zumindest ist die Katze nicht tot, das hätten wir mitgekriegt.
Wisst ihr was, wir porten uns jetzt einfach einmal hin und einmal zurück, dann resettert die Katze bestimmt.
Trick 17. Was ist denn das?
Wir porten uns jetzt einfach einmal runter und einmal hoch.
Wir reisen jetzt zum Strand, das geht aber mega schnell.
Wo ist die Katze? Ich habe keine Ahnung wo die Katze hin ist.
Aber ja gut, gehen wir ein bisschen weiter erkunden.
Ich meine, hier haben wir sie zuletzt gesehen. Die Katze ist bestimmt wieder da, wo sie das erste Mal war, wenn man zu weit weg rennt.
Okay, gehen wir mal weiter gucken. Was ist denn hier unten? Loot.
Wie viel XP habe ich eigentlich? Wo sieht man das?
Wo sieht man eigentlich, wie viel XP ich noch brauche?
Ah hier, nächste Stufe. Okay, ich brauche noch eine Weile bis Level 3.
Da gucke ich, da hätte ich nie im Leben hingeguckt, gelber Balken unten.
Ich brauche alles, was für meinen gestaltenden Wanderer zeugt.
Kann ich ja immer noch holen.
Oh, ja mit dem haben wir uns auch gekloppt schon, ganz am Anfang.
Wo geht es denn hier landen?
Ist das nicht der Typ, den der eine auf der Mauer gesucht hat?
Wie lange ich schon spiele? Ich würde mal sagen drei Stunden oder so. Aber ich bin nicht sonderlich schnell gerade.
Ah, ja doch das ist der Typ, den der auf der Mauer gesucht hat.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich werde mich jetzt gleich mit dem kloppen müssen.
Deswegen stellen wir Lose mal. Lose ich will nicht mit dir reden, ich will, dass du irgendwo hinläufst.
Lose und Ivan stellen wir mal.
Sibylle ist eigentlich eher sowas für den dran. Ich habe eigentlich nur eine Frontline, das ist mein Held.
So und Sibylle stellt sich... Moment wie kann man sich noch mal tarnen?
Unauffällig, unauffällig sind wir. So jetzt speichern wir mal das Gehstab am Held hin. Vielleicht greift er mich hier an.
Nein, bleibt stehen Jungs. Stehen bleiben, stehen bleiben, stehen bleiben.
Das geht.
Was? Wo was wächst? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Hm, mir bleibt nicht... Oh der hat aber viel... Der ist relativ stark hier. Der schreckt mich bestimmt.
Ich versuche mich mal... Ich sage ihm, dass ich ihm nicht helfen kann.
Sandro Volta darf ich fragen, wieso spielst du eigentlich kein Overwatch mehr? Das liegt nicht an Overwatch selbst, sondern am Ranked Modus von Overwatch. Das gibt kaum was demotivierendes für mich als Overwatch Ranked.
Was willst du von mir? Was will das Fisch?
Das sagen wir zu ihm.
Oh, ich habe jetzt nicht gedacht, dass er mich angreift. Oh fuck, Alter, das geht mir nicht mehr ab.
Oh, der macht aber Damage.
So, Lose. Lose macht Regen und elektrifiziert ihn.
Oh nee, the fuck, warum? Warum habe ich das jetzt auch abgekriegt? Ich bin doch weit genug weg gewesen. Scheiße.
Ich muss jetzt mal mit Lose abhauen. So, jetzt ist mein Zwerch dran.
Oh fuck, da hat er noch Rüstung.
Oh, ey, der Typ, der macht ja mega Damage.
Das muss ich glaube ich nochmal neu anfangen, mich ordentlich aufstellen. Der ist ja mittendrinne hier, das ist ganz schön ein Mist, der.
Das ist aber echt kacke.
Irgendwie gefällt mir das nicht, ich muss meine Helden ordentlich aufstellen.
So kann ich jetzt eigentlich, oh fuck, das ist übelst kacke.
Ich muss das echt nochmal neu laden.
Okay, wir hauen jetzt mal ein Stückchen ab. Ah, Scheiße. Fuck.
Nee, Feuerfall bringt nichts, Gift. Nee, Gift heilt ihn. Fuck, eins kann ich nur draufschießen.
Okay, Sibylla trinkt mal einen Heiltrank.
Okay, machen wir mal Damage von hinten drauf.
Kann man sich jetzt noch tarnen oder so? Nee, ne?
Was ist das, du hältst sofort zwei Aktionsbrecher? Nee, das brauche ich nicht.
Und drüber springen will ich auch nicht.
So, ich muss auf jeden Fall mal an den Typ ran.
Aber ich habe noch genug Rüstung. Können wir einfach mal draufhauen.
Der Typ macht Damage, ey. Ist ja gut.
Hallo Tofu Wal. Okay, da ist in die Richtung gedreht. Das heißt, ich kann jetzt zumindest mal mit, ich kann mich nicht bewegen, wird ja immer besser.
Moment. Trefft das Verbündete?
Wir gehen mal ein Stückchen weg. Wir können ja nicht gehen, haben wir schon ganz vergessen.
Scheiße.
Heißt, sagt mir das jetzt, dass ich meinen Verbündeten Damage mache oder nicht?
Okay, doch, es macht ihn was. Perfekt, wird er immer besser. Na toll.
Hat er noch Rüstung? Er hat immer noch Rüstung.
Okay, jetzt die Rüstung weg.
Sibylle ist eingefroren, ganz toll gemacht. Max, super, perfekt.
Kann man Sibylle irgendwie buffen?
Jetzt frisst er wenigstens Damage.
Bam. Oh, was macht er da? Oh, der macht, oh, der macht, oh Scheiße, macht er Damage.
Fuck, man, warum macht er so viel Damage?
Okay. Los, trink mal deinen Heiltrank.
Kann man sonst noch was machen?
Ja, Ivan, trink auch mal deinen Heiltrank und schieß einfach mal drauf.
Komm, scheiß drauf, schieß einfach mal drauf.
Und ich würde sagen, Ivan, hau mal ab.
Moment, warum? Der Typ ist geschockt, der kann nicht zurückschlagen.
WTF? Ich glaube, ich habe das Kampfsystem noch nicht so ganz gecheckt.
Ich fürchte, wir müssen das nochmal neu laden.
Zumal er ja auch geheilt wird, wenn er hier drinne steht.
Was geht mit dem Typ ab? Super, Sibylle ist down.
Okay, ich muss das nochmal neu laden. Das funktioniert nicht so ganz, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Fuck, Alter. Nee, ich lade das nochmal neu und stelle mich mal ordentlich auf.
Futter mal meine Frikadelle. Oder vielleicht muss man den Typ gerade nicht brechen.
Machs gut, MDG, play.
Wir stellen die zwei hier hinten auf. Das ist eigentlich okay.
Wir stellen die beiden hier hinten auf. Sibylle darf irgendwo da hinten in die Ecke schleichen.
Was? Schleichen? Moment.
Sibylle, warum kannst du nicht schleichen? Nichts kann sie.
Hallo Tommy. Jetzt aber, jetzt wird er gebashed.
Ha, evaded. Evaded, jetzt geht es ab, die Sibylle.
Moment, warum ist es jetzt zu weit weg? Jetzt ist es natürlich zu weit weg für Ivan. Super.
Aber nicht weit. Da reicht es, wenn ich den Schritt vorgehe. Ist genug.
Noch eine Runde gebufft.
Boah, hier bei dem Kampfsystem muss man echt aufpassen. Jetzt darf ich hier nicht durchlaufen mit meinem Zwerg, sonst bin ich geschockt.
Jetzt wird Sibylle ihn schrecken.
Das hat jetzt nicht so viel Damage gemacht. Was haben wir sonst noch?
Werd ich jetzt geschockt, wenn ich hier hinter ihn springe?
Verfehlt.
Moment, Sibylle wird gar nicht ge...
Vielleicht kann ich hier auch durchchargen. Jawoll, nice, funktioniert.
Was, wo rennt der hin?
Der Typ, der will es echt wissen. Jetzt rennt er auch noch zu meinen Kars dann hinter.
Ivan zündet ihn einfach mal an.
Was? Ivan, wo hast du denn hingeschossen jetzt? Das war ja mal gar nichts.
Wieso nicht erst Gift, dann Anzünden. Der war ja gerade im Gift. Das Problem ist, dass das Anzünden nicht funktioniert hat, weil er hier noch Schild hat. Der Typ ist aber echt hartnäckig.
Okay, machen wir jetzt mal Regen und dann Eis.
Wir machen Regen und jetzt Eis.
Ich kann mich nicht wirklich bewegen gerade.
3 AP reicht nicht, super.
Ist der wieder da hinten hin gerannt, da komm ich doch nie hin. Ich kann jetzt hier vorchargen.
Oh, hab ich jetzt Ivan getroffen? Nee, oder? Jetzt macht der eigentlich nichts. Friendly Fire. Das kann ich nicht machen, der hat zu viel... oh fuck. Das nervt mich jetzt aber.
Ich kann im Prinzip jetzt auch nur da ranlaufen. Wir geben uns einfach mal jetzt Schild. Das andere fällt mir gerade nicht ein.
Wie viel kostet das 2 Punkte? Oh fuck. Der Typ macht so krass Damage.
Und Ivan kriegt richtig auf den Sack. Egal, wir machen dem jetzt Damage. Scheiß drauf, ich bleib jetzt einfach stehen.
Ich hebe mir meinen Heal auf für die nächste Runde. Jetzt kann ich nicht heilen.
Kann schon mal drauf schießen. Wir buffen uns noch mal.
Was? Alter! Das macht mich fertig, das Kampfsystem.
Vergiftet ist schlecht, vergiftet heilt ihn.
Ich hab geblockt, nice. Komm, ich schieße jetzt einfach. Ich sehe nichts, wo ist er?
Okay, jetzt machen wir wenigstens Damage. Also wirklich heilen bringt jetzt eigentlich nichts mich zu heilen.
Darf sie Bille jetzt mal wieder irgendwas machen?
Ja, was mache ich jetzt mit ihr? Kriegt das jetzt einer von mir ab, wenn ich den Elektro schocke oder nicht?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich probiere es mal aus. Alter, warum kriegt die das ab? Da ist doch überhaupt nichts.
Ich verstehe das nicht. Das check ich nicht. Newplay ist ja aber richtig. Scheiß drauf, ich mach jetzt Damage.
Macht sie Bille halt die ganze Runde nichts. Die steht im Wasser? Die steht überhaupt nicht im Wasser.
Das Game denkt aber, dass sie im Wasser steht. Oder meint sie, dass das da ist Wasser? Nee, das ist kein Wasser.
Vor allem, warum trifft die das nicht? Jetzt wird er geschreckt.
Ich habe noch richtig viel Leben, außer sie Bille. Jetzt kann ich den Knockdown.
Jawoll. Jetzt macht er erstmal nichts mehr. Bäm. Sonst macht es... Ivan, dann machen wir mal eine Runde Damage.
Deinen Zug verzögern. Was passiert dann? Ah, sehr schön. Was kann Lose denn jetzt machen?
Ich verzöge auch mal meinen Zug. Genau, weil jetzt ist sie Bille dran. Ich kann ihn jetzt endlich mal bashen.
In den Kegel muss ich gehen. Was? Moment. Warum hat Ivan jetzt Damage gekriegt? Bin ich überhaupt drinnen?
Das macht schön Damage. Warum kriegen die alle Damage?
Okay, Lose kann im Endeffekt, wenn ich das richtig höre, kann Lose nichts machen. Außer Mehl draufhauen.
Wir können Eis machen. Eis kann ja nichts passieren.
Das hat ihn auch aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht getroffen. Okay.
Ivan, halt jetzt die Bille. Oh fuck. Ich dachte, er ist jetzt Downer Typ. Komm. Oh nee.
Nein, das überlebe ich. Bäm. Ivan, du kriegst viel zu viel Damage. Jetzt mache ich dich kalt.
Raus hier. Raus hier. Raus hier aus dem Gift. Komm. Kommt her.
Verreckt. Allen Ernstes. Allen Ernstes, ihr seid jetzt noch verreckt danach. Aber ich habe eine Wiederbelebungsrolle.
So, erstmal ausruhen. Bille, ich will dich wiederbeleben. Was?
Was Ziel ist blockiert? Von was ist denn bitteschön Ziel blockiert? Was zum? So bewegt euch mal. Kommt mal her.
Jetzt wollen wir erstmal die Bille wiederbeleben. Hä? Geht doch. Kann Ivan sie jetzt heilen? Nee, müssen wir ja gar nicht.
Wir können einfach nochmal eine Runde pennen. Was ein Act ey. Was ein Act. Alter. Not my LoL, genau.
Okay, der Typ der war Level 4 und gut ausgerüstet. Okay, wir machen jetzt mit Lose nochmal eine Runde Regen.
Dass das Gift hier weggeht. Falls das überhaupt von Regen weggeht, geht das von Regen weg. Da müssten jetzt Wolken kommen.
Okay, looten. Nice, nice, nice.
Das nehmen wir. Ich würde sagen, das ziehen wir uns auch gleich an.
Aber hallo, ziehen wir uns das an. Tiedrich, Gold. Also das hat sich gelohnt. Die Rüstung ist schon mal ziemlich nice.
Gibt es hier sonst noch was? So Leute, kommt mal her. Das passt schon.
Ihr könnt, genau, rennt mal wenn es geht nicht durch die Wolke durch. Schatzkiste. Arm.
Ah, ich kann jetzt meine Elfen das fressen lassen.
Okay, genau. Sibylle kriegt ganzen Erme, Beine und sonst was. Haben wir noch mehr davon?
Das ziehe ich jetzt mal mit meinem. So, das sieht viel stylischer aus gleich.
Haben wir sonst noch irgendwelche abgerissenen Körperteile, die man uns füttern kann? Ich glaube, das war's.
Mal schauen, was passiert. Was passiert, wenn ihr das Zeug isst?
Okay, das war jetzt relativ unspektakulär, was er da erfahren hat.
Ich bin Finn. Was, ich bin der Mashed? Was heißt das denn? Ist Finn nicht der Typ, der auf dem Schiff am Anfang umgebracht wurde?
Hm.
Okay. So viele Quests.
Looten.
Gibt es hier sonst noch irgendwas?
Nee, ich glaube, das war's. Gut, haben wir den Abschnitt fertig. Zu Griff müssen wir, genau.
Gehen wir mal zu Griff.
Was ist mit dem Typ da los? Was ist Griff?
Ja, wir sind ja eigentlich doch in Kuta. Wir bringen ihm das Zeug wieder.
So, mit Griff müssen wir eh reden.
Mit der haben wir nun nicht geredet.
Okay.
Was ist mit dem Typ da los?
Ja, machen wir mal das.
Moment, Orangen? Wir haben doch Orangen. Die haben wir doch dem Exentyp abgenommen. Guck mal.
Jetzt können wir den bestimmt geben und alles ist gut.
Nein, egal.
Wir wissen schon, dass der Exentyp das hatte. Wir haben den schon längst um die Ecke gebracht.
Dann geben wir immer seine Orange wieder.
Oh nee, Sibylle macht den Typ jetzt kalt, oder?
Wenn ich Sibylle jetzt erlaufe mit dem Typ zu reden, dann muckst du den ab.
Okay, ich probiere das mal aus. Ich lasse mal Sibylle mit ihm reden.
Okay, probiere das mal aus.
Übrigens, ist Eva nicht auch einer von den einsamen Wölfen? Irgendwie ergibt das noch keinen Sinn.
Was? Sibylle hat ihn nicht gekillt? Was ist da los?
Okay, gut. Sie hat den wenigstens nicht abgemuckst.
Griff, ich habe deine Orange schon dabei.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich ihm das sagen soll.
Oh, das gab fett XP.
So, jetzt macht er da auf. Dann kriege ich wahrscheinlich hier noch mal XP.
Dann erzählen wir dem Typ oben auf der Mauer, dass wir Miko um die Ecke gebracht haben.
Und dann haben wir Level Up. Aber wir haben jetzt schon Level Up.
Sehr, sehr nice.
Moment, ich rede ja mit Ivan. Na gut.
So far.
Machen wir, machen wir.
Jetzt erzählen wir dem Typ auf der Mauer noch, dass wir Miko um die Ecke gebracht haben.
Wo ist eigentlich die Katze? Ich suche immer noch die Katze.
Der Typ wollte wissen, wo Miko ist. Wir haben Miko gefunden und abgemuckst.
Genau.
Keine Details. Tja, was erzähle ich dem jetzt? Auf Deutsch? Ja Fabian, auf Deutsch.
Bist du mittlerweile aufgestanden?
Erzähle ich dem jetzt was Sache ist?
Wisst ihr was? Ich speicher jetzt einfach mal.
Und ich sage ihm, ich habe ihn um die Ecke gebracht.
Der Ring? Moment, will ich ihr den Ring überhaupt geben?
Will ich ihr den Ring geben? Weil es ist echt nice, einen Ring mit Regeneration zu haben.
Eigentlich will ich ihr den Ring nicht geben.
Genau, Fabian, als würdest du das anders machen, ne? Speicher cheat.
Okay, gucken wir mal was passiert, wenn wir ihr den Ring geben.
Oh.
Ist vielleicht nicht so gut, dass ich ihr erzählt habe, dass ich ihn um die Ecke gebracht habe, oder?
Der Karsten schaut zu.
Okay, da gehen wir hinterher jetzt.
Da gehen wir hinterher. Dann gibt es nämlich bestimmt nochmal ein bisschen mehr Reward.
Go, go, go.
Moment.
Moment, was? Was?
Was macht der NPC da?
Ah, okay jetzt hat der NPC den Weg gefunden.
Was? Alter, verpiss dich.
Oh fuck, die kennen sich auch noch.
Fuck, ich wollte jetzt dem anderen nachlaufen.
Okay, dann muss ich jetzt gleich an den Strand.
Ups.
Okay, wo ist jetzt der kacke NPC hin?
Und ich frag mich immer noch, wo die Katze hin ist. Die Katze ist einfach weg.
Ist der NPC jetzt hier? Wo ist der hin gerannt? Oh Mann.
Moment, unter Grundtunnel.
Oh fuck, ich habe keine Schaufel. Okay, das muss ich mir merken.
Da muss ich graben dann noch, wenn ich eine Schaufel habe.
Ich glaube, die ist jetzt nicht so gut auf mich zu sprechen.
Hey, hätte ich dir mal nicht den Ring gegeben.
Ich glaube, ich werde jetzt nochmal laden und den Ring behalten.
Okay, Questlog, haben wir noch so einen Questlog.
Wo sieht man, dass Ashi wird?
Das? Nein, das wird jetzt geladen. Ich behalte den Ring. Stop, es geht los.
Ich dachte, da gibt es wenigstens noch einen ordentlichen Reward, aber nein.
Erst mal schön cheaten.
Z Pro 1000, was ist das für ein Game?
Das ist ein isometrisches RPG, kam vor zwei oder drei Tagen raus.
Ein bisschen im Stil von alten RPGs wie Baldur's Gate.
Der erste Teil war auch schon extrem gut. Nein, nein, ich habe ihn nicht gesehen.
Ja, ich habe ihn gesehen.
Ja, dann nicht.
Ist hier sonst noch irgendetwas? Nope.
Oh nee, das darf ich nicht looten.
Erst mal looten, bevor wir hier weiter gehen.
Was interessieren mich die Leute hier? Erst mal looten.
Wir gehen noch mal raus, wir gehen erst noch mal am Strand ein bisschen rumgucken.
Ah, ich kann jetzt ja Lose beibringen mit Tieren zu sprechen, das ist wichtig.
Tier Freund, bringen wir das Lose? Ja, das bringen wir Lose bei.
Ja, Lose, geh mal mit dir runter.
Was? Ich habe das doch gerade Lose beigebracht.
So, wenn ich jetzt mal endlich die Katze wieder finden würde, dann könnte ich auch mal fragen, was die eigentlich will.
Nö, ich will nichts kochen.
Haben wir hier noch was? Nope.
Krabbe, mit der Krabbe darf Lose jetzt reden.
Haha.
Okay, das hat es jetzt nicht wirklich gebracht.
Was sagt die eigentlich, wenn man mit ihr redet, ohne dass man reden kann? Nix.
Nix drin, nichts drin. Also die ganzen Fässer, die sie hier verteilt haben, die könnte man eigentlich auch sich zum größten Teil sparen.
Oh, Moment, das Game hat gespeichert, das ist meistens ein Zeichen für, dass jetzt gleich irgendwas passiert.
Kann man mit jedem Tier reden? Ja, soweit ich weiß schon, solange du halt das Talent für hast.
Oh, Krokodile. Fette Krokodile, die werden jetzt geschreckt.
Krokodile bashen.
Oh, Moment. Moment, irgendwie ist jeder außer meinem Held im Kampf. Ich glaube, das ist nicht so gewollt.
Okay, nee, ich glaube, das hat ein bisschen rumgebackt gerade.
Oh, die Bille schreckt den Typ jetzt mal richtig.
Mehr Punkte. Die macht übelst Damage. Das Engagement ist jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Oh, da sind aber einige Krokodile am Start. Was geht mit dem ab?
Was ist mit dem Krokodil los? Ich glaube, ich sollte das Ganze nochmal laden und mal ordentlich hier.
Ich wollte ja überhaupt nicht kämpfen mit denen. Also jetzt noch nicht, ich wollte mich erstmal ordentlich hinstellen.
Sibylle hackt jetzt mal weiter auf dem Viech rum.
Ach, Moment. Gar nicht. Wer ist denn überhaupt dran? Lose ist dran.
Eingefrorenes Krokodil.
Aber so viele Mops sollst du eine Moab zünden. Genau, das ist die Moab.
Ich mache mich jetzt mal vom Acker, weil irgendwie gefällt mir das nicht, dass da ein Krokodil rumsteht.
Das ist allgemein blöd, weil Lose steht ja da mittendrin. Mit der kann ich gleich abhauen. Wo ist mein Zwerg überhaupt da?
Jetzt rushen wir da mal ran. Wie viele Punkte kostet das? Zwei.
Ein Stückchen näher. Bam! Schreckt. Mit Lose haue ich jetzt mal wieder ab.
Wenn ich keinen Bock habe, dass mich das Krokodil hier oben gleich ahnt.
Ist das Krokodil hier kaputt? Ach nee, Ivan, nix kriegste gebacken. Alter, was geht mit dem ab? Warum kann sich ein Krokodil teleportieren?
Was ist denn das? Warum kannst du das Krokodil teleportieren? Was soll das?
Also die Krokodile sind merkwürdige Krokodile.
Erst mal Knockdown. Ich muss weg. Kann ich das Krokodil schocken, dass ich das nicht bewegen kann?
Ach fuck. Jetzt ahnt mich das gleich. Ach du Scheiße, macht das Damage. Ich glaube, das muss ich nochmal neu laden.
Was ist mit dem Krokodil los ey? Was ist mit dem Krokodil los? Scheiß draufschlagt es jetzt nochmal. Scheiß Engagement.
Teleportierende Krokodile. Was geht? Vielleicht soll ich einfach mal meine Skillpunkte verteilen.
So, lose darf sich schon mal stelzen.
Sibylle. Das ist mega OP. Das ist mega OP, das brauchen wir jetzt. Wir skillen mit Sibylle jetzt einmal Kriegsführung.
Wo ist es denn? Wir skillen mit Sibylle jetzt einmal Kriegsführung und dann... Moment. What the fuck?
Oh, haben die das gepatcht Scyther Beta? Das ist ja fies. Man kann Sibylle nicht mehr das...
Ah, das hört auf. Das ist ja blöd. So, jetzt skillen wir erstmal unseren Zwerg.
Oh, perfekt. Schönen Tank.
Das ist kein Fehler, das ist schon so gedacht, aber das war halt mega OP.
Gucken, was ich skille. Muss ich bei klein nochmal überlegen. Erstmal mal die Krokodile platt.
Nicht rum, Sibylle. So, Sibylle, stell dich. Stell dich mal da hin. Ivan, stell dich da oben hin.
Ja genau, stellt ihr euch mal da oben hin, das ist schon gut. So, perfekt. Jetzt geht sie ran.
Das juckt mich nicht. Das juckt mich so überhaupt nicht, ob ihr auch mal Zwerg drauf haut oder nicht.
Ey, die Teleport Krokodile, die machen mich fertig. Warum teleportieren die sich?
Das Gute ist, dass mein Zwerg so ein richtig krasser Tank ist, dem macht das alles nichts.
Das juckt den überhaupt nicht. Who cares.
Nice, funktioniert. Oder? Funktioniert nicht? Wenn ich jetzt bis dahin laufe, geht das jetzt?
Ja oder? Reicht das? Reicht das? Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das reicht.
Kommen wir jetzt mal aus, ob das reicht. Jawoll, hat funktioniert.
Ah, Lose ist dran, ok. Sibylle kriegt das nicht ab. Moment, ich speicher mal kurz.
Handjob speichern? Speicher mal kurz. Ich weiß nämlich nicht, ob ich mich jetzt selbst schocke, weil ich im Öl stehe.
Ok, das nicht. Sehr schön.
Ivan macht den Typ mal kaputt hier. Oh, das macht Damage.
Das macht ordentlich Damage. So, jetzt ist Sibylle dran. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob ich mit Sibylle da reinspringen soll. Hallo Ero-X.
Aber die ist halt beweglich wie Sauna. Die kann den kompletten...
Ok, Sibylle haunt das Viech jetzt.
Sibylle schreckt das jetzt. Oh, ok.
Ein Damage noch. Und jetzt laufen wir mal ein Stückchen weg, weil ich keinen Bock habe, dass mich die Krokodili zuauen.
Jetzt ist es eingefroren, perfekt.
Moment, ist es jetzt wieder aufgetaut? Oh fuck, so war das nicht geplant.
Kann Ivan den treffen? Ja, das müsste gerade so gehen. Perfekt. Das klappt ja richtig gut.
Oh nee, geh weg. Oh, das macht Damage, das Viech. Alter, das macht das Damage, das ist doch nicht normal. Ich muss das bashen.
Oh, ich kann Sibylle heilen, das ist gut. Das heilt richtig viel.
Was? Ziel ist blockiert? Nope. Was soll das?
Zum Schlusspunkt kann ich schon irgendwas Sinnvolles machen. Aber nicht wirklich. Sibylle kann das Viech jetzt auen.
Oh, ich kann die Krokodile jetzt direkt vor dem Viech heilen. Wenn ich jetzt weglaufe, hittet mich das dann? Ich habe die Mechanik noch nicht so genau kapiert, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Fuck. Okay, das ist doof.
TheRomanjo, ja, am Montag muss ich dir sagen, kauf dir Alienware.
Irgendwie ist es merkwürdig, hier mit Schurke zu spielen, weil sobald du einmal im Nahkampf drinnen bist, die Mops sind clever, die hauen dich. Was für eine Schurke Kacke ist, weil er übelst Damage frisst.
Und abhauen kann ich gerade nicht. Wir müssen das Viech jetzt einfach killen.
Mit Lose kann ich den wirklich was machen gerade.
Oh nee, jetzt kommt das Teleport Krokodil. Die Krokodile, was geht da los?
So, Ivan. Ivan macht das Ding mal kaputt jetzt. Welches machen wir denn jetzt kaputt? Das da, das da, das haben wir mal kaputt. Das sollten wir hinkriegen.
Gucken wir, wie viel Damage Ivan macht. Wer kommt denn als nächstes dran? Keiner. Hm, kriegen wir das irgendwie kaputt? Da müssen wir aber echt glücklich treffen, dass das was bringt.
Jawoll, wo bloß? Mach ihn kalt. Jetzt wird's geschreckt, das Viech.
Riecht das irgendwie kaputt? Riecht das kaputt? Nein, hier kann ich wenigstens draufhornen. Hier kann ich nicht draufhornen, das ist zu weit weg. Aber als nächstes kommt Sibylla, die macht sie alle tot.
Oh, das kack Viech, äh.
Jetzt schreckt. Kann sich nicht mehr bewegen. Ich brauch unbedingt mit Lose noch ein bisschen mehr Spells, weil ich hab viel zu, viel zu kleine Anzahl an Spells.
Jawoll, kaputt ist es. Ähm. Ist das nicht heute der letzte Tag für eine neutrale Meinung? Nee, ich werd euch auch am Montag nicht irgendwie irgendeinen Scheiß empfehlen.
Das war doch ein guter Fight jetzt. Alienware ist gut für Leute, die einfach was suchen, was funktioniert. Sich damit nicht großartig beschäftigen wollen. Dafür ist es echt nicht verkehrt.
Oh, krass. Geil.
Kostenloser Teleport, easy. Ja, das ist nice. Einfach mal von so einem random Scheiß Krokodil.
Zeugst du noch auf Konsole? Eigentlich gar nicht mehr. Von so einem Krokodil übertriebenste OP-Handschuhe.
Na, gibt's hier wieder Zeug für meine, für mein Elf zum Fressen?
Vielleicht soll ich Lose auch mal ne ordentliche Rüstung anziehen, ha?
Wow. Moment. Ist das jetzt mehr Rüstung als vorher?
Naja. Okay, das ist also übliche Fantasy-Rüstung. Je besser die Rüstung, umso weniger an.
Ich muss eh mal für meine Leute ordentliches Equipment kaufen. Das ist ja echt das total freudige Zeug.
Ah, was hat denn hier Sibylla alles? Zeugs zum Futtern, jawoll. Und mein Eingeweide hatten wir doch mit... haben ich doch hier mit ihm auch gesammelt.
Wenn man sie frisst.
Moment, kurz pennen, alles gut. Ähm, da werde ich schon mit Sibylla den restlichen Kram noch futtern.
Okay.
Gibt's hier noch was? Jetzt haben wir aber die mega geilen Handschuhe. Guckt euch das mal an. Teleportzwerk.
Ah, ich kann nicht mich selbst teleportieren oder was?
Gut, dann ziehe ich die Handschuhe vielleicht doch lieber lose oder so an. Aber die hat schon ganz gute.
Aber zu lose passen die am besten. Komm, ich ziehe jetzt erst mal hier Sibylla, kriegt jetzt die Handschuhe.
Haben wir sonst noch irgendwelche Sachen? Ausrüstung, Handschuhe.
Ein bisschen paar ordentliche Sachen anziehen. Ja, das sieht heute schon besser aus.
Okay. Moment, warum habe ich hier so Dinge?
Intelligenz. Intelligenz ist was, was lose braucht.
Ah, natürlich kann ich nicht anziehen, weil ich habe ja logisch. Das funktioniert natürlich nicht. Ich habe hier noch das Halsband um.
Also erst noch mal hier beste Rüstung überhaupt. Mir fehlt echt so ein bisschen die Ausrüstung.
Aber klar, schon mal alles. Jetzt haben wir schon mal alles immer noch ausgerüstet, was wir haben.
Der Stamp ist aber viel besser. Sogar drei Rüstungen.
So, dann gucken wir doch mal, wie das jetzt mit dem teleportieren funktioniert.
Okay, nice. Wisst ihr, was wir machen? Ich erinnere mich da an was. Ganz am Start war eine Kiste, an die wir nicht rangekommen sind.
Hier drüben, hier drüben ist doch irgendwo der Start. Nee. Aber irgendwo hier war das.
Dann teleportieren wir nämlich zu der Kiste hoch. Und ich suche immer noch die Katze.
Sind die, sind die Skills von, steht nichts da? Es steht nichts davon da, dass die Skills nur ein paar Mal einsetzbar sind.
Guck, warte mal. Steht nichts von da. Also ich würde mal sagen, kannst du so oft einsetzen, wie du willst.
Schlafsack haben wir schon. Kochtopf. Ah, eine Schaufel. Na endlich.
Da können wir buddeln. Irgendwo am Strand konnten wir buddeln.
Hier. Die Markierung ist verschwunden, aber irgendwo hier konnte man buddeln. Irgendwo hier war was zum Graben.
Hier drüben meinte ich genau. Da können wir uns bestimmt hin teleportieren.
Dann kommen wir immer noch nicht. Aber teleportieren können wir.
Den dicken Zwerg. Was? Das geht bestimmt. Man muss das nur von der richtigen Stelle aus machen.
Oder haben wir teleportieren die Kiste runter. Eins von beiden.
Sollen wir safen? Weiß er nie, ob da eine Falle ist oder so.
Das ist nicht übel. Ich habe es ja ganz am Anfang gesagt, ich lege mich nicht fest auf eine Waffenkategorie.
Weil jetzt hätte ich mich geärgert, hätte ich ein Hand gespeckt.
Wisst ihr was, wir versuchen jetzt noch mal zu cheaten. Mal gucken, ob das noch funktioniert wie im ersten Teil. Im ersten Teil waren manche Kisten random.
Und wenn einem der Inhalt nicht gefallen hat, hat man einfach noch mal geladen und noch mal neu aufgemacht.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es diesmal wieder den gleichen Fehler drin hat.
Moment. Moment. Das sind die gleichen Items aber mit anderen Stats drauf.
Das Schwert ist ja noch krasser als das letzte.
Hallo Reax. Jetzt haben wir schon mal Kisten gecheatet.
Moment, ich probiere das jetzt aus. Das muss ich jetzt leider noch mal ausprobieren, ob das wirklich so ist.
Ob das wirklich so ist, wie ich mir das denke. Kisten cheat.
Also es ist so ein Zwischending, wie aus dem ersten und dem zweiten Teil. Die Waffen, also die Kategorien der Items sind fest.
Allerdings ändert sich die Stats. Habt ihr das gesehen?
Ich lade das letzte wieder jetzt. Das bringt ja nichts, wenn ich den ganzen Tag hier neue Items würfel.
Zumal das ja, das grenzt ja schon an beschissen.
Ich finde es cool, dass das immer noch geht.
Jetzt haben wir mal eine richtig krasse Rüstung.
Und ein übelst gutes Zweihänderschwert.
Gut die Rüstung brauche ich jetzt mit meinem Zwerg nicht wirklich, weil der hat schon eine noch bessere Rüstung.
Geben wir das mal. Wir hatten jetzt Rüstung am nötigsten hier gerade von meinen Typen.
Ivan. Ivan hat eindeutig. Ivan braucht Rüstung.
Jetzt kippt Ivan immer gleich aus den Latschen.
Warum zum Teufel kann auf einmal Ivan Tierfreund?
Hatte Ivan schon die ganze Zeit Tierfreund? Ich habe bloß so umsonst Tierfreund geskillt.
Ist klar. Warum bin ich jetzt runtergefallen? Komm Zwerg noch mal hoch. Was ist das für ein Game?
RPG. So mal gucken was es hier oben gibt. Theoretisch könnte ich jetzt ja damit mit ziviler alle hoch porten.
Aha Hemd. Schriftrolle. Oh guck mal hier ist ein Turm. Ist aber nichts. Zwerg wo willst du hin?
Soll ich jetzt runter stürzen oder was? Super hast du toll gemacht.
Okay. Okay wo geht es weiter? Buddeln wir müssen buddeln am Strand.
Also ich glaube die Katze ist gebugged. Weil die Katze war am Strand war die noch da.
Und jetzt finde ich sie nirgendwo mehr. Ich glaube die Katze ist gebugged.
Also Romanto ich kann dir auch nur empfehlen ich würde nicht unbedingt am Gehäuse sparen.
Gescheites Gehäuse, gescheites Netzteil. Auch was Lärmentwicklung angeht und sowas.
So wer hat denn von mir noch mal ne Schaufel? Ah nice.
Ne Tunnel. Ich hab so das Gefühl ich entdecke hier alles ohne das Story zu folgen.
Was gibt es denn hier schönes? Was gibt es denn hier schönes?
Äh da verrecken gerade Viecher. Ich speicher das nochmal.
Okay Wasser kann man bestimmt immer brauchen. Das kann auch gar nicht so schwer das Ding. Auch genug Stärke.
Handschuhe? Ich glaube es haben doch nicht alle meine Charaktere Handschuhe an. Ich fand es ja wirklich da hat der nichts.
Kinderhandschuhe ist ein Top 5 Werk passt gut.
Und was das? Da muss schon mal mit Lose hin. Mit der Reden.
What?
Ist das irgendein Viech aus dem ersten Teil? Also das Ding hier auf jeden Fall. Das war der Boss aus dem ersten Akt.
Das Ding hier auf jeden Fall.
A mood will only darken, I fear.
Her own courtiers can do little to cheer her.
And outsiders?
Well, outsiders rarely survive a war.
Truly?
Then perhaps the tyrants has fallen.
And my princess might be free.
Be sure to tell her.
Gibt... Ja, es gibt eine neue iPhone App. Ich hab gestern ein Update installiert, aber noch nicht geguckt.
Also, das, die letzte iPhone App, die letzte... Ah, nee, es gibt noch ein neues Update. Das muss ich mir jetzt gleich mal angucken.
Okay.
Installier ich mir jetzt mal ne neue Twitch App. Weil das letzte Update von der Twitch App war ja grausig.
so viel anders sieht es nicht aus aber vielleicht vielleicht ruckelt das jetzt
im chat nicht mehr so ich werde jetzt an der stelle immer
speichern ich glaube mir reicht das ja da
schuhe socken aber schuhe könnte ich auch brauchen schon nicht
waren sehr lauter
gibt es eigentlich schon chat im single player modus
da geht es ja rauf wusste schon gar nicht
moment hier geht es lang
plus ein siegers mann das ist doch eindeutig schwarz für ifa
accommodation
Was?
Was? Geht ab!
Was? Ist das für ne Quest? Ich soll jetzt nen Mann für ne Schnecke suchen oder was?
Was? Ist das für ne Quest? Ich soll jetzt nen Mann für ne Schnecke suchen oder was? Dir das auch nix vorhin gefallen.
Ah ok, das ist ja cool. Man redet automatisch wohl mit dem Charakter, der mit Tieren reden kann.
Ey so schnell kanns gehen. Einmal mit dem falschen Held angeredet. Bam in your face.
Gut, dass ich gespeichert hab. Man muss in dem Game wirklich laufen speichern.
So eigentlich wollte ich Schluss machen, fällt mir gerade auf.
Mal gucken wo es hier lang geht.
Das war mal mit der Hand und nichts.
ich habe stärke das ist auch ein bisschen fies egal überreden erfolgreich
moment
ich suche kein ach so na doch schon also wie es aus dem tunnel geht weiß ich ja
in
Oben ist was grün, weiß nicht ob ich hier schon rumlaufen sollte mit meinem level
verschlossen okay ich glaube probieren wir doch mal das schlösser knacken von siebille aus
heil cliffhänger probieren wir doch mal das schlösser knacken von siebille aus was hat die
denn hier
also mal siebille schlösser knacken hey hat funktioniert nice easy
ja du bist nicht der erste der das gesagt hat vorhin meinte auch einer erinnert
einen dungeon sie mit den halsbändern ich weiß nicht ob ich hier schon rumlaufen sollte
hier ist alles verschlossen das kann nicht so sind zweck der sache seine gibt bestimmt
von den schlüssel ich muss es den schlüssel geben wo geht es denn hier lang
der will nicht raus kein bock ja los und macht das mal laber mit dem
tommatensauce
das das pauschetz unbedingt
der monologe ist klar
ich frage mich wieviel stunden und wieviel voice actor typen die gebraucht haben wenn
die wirklich den kompletten text hier in dem game vertont haben im ersten teil war war
nur schlüssel dialogue so weit ich mich erinnern kann vertont und ich habe sie wirklich alles
vertont es geht mit dem app
vielleicht sollte uns erzählen wie das wie das heißt
was sie bitte mal wieder
was mache ich da eigentlich
eine ratte aber muss jetzt da muss lose ran
die haben wirklich alles vertont das muss ein riesen aufwand gewesen sein
ich habe in den letzten drei wochen oder so kein pubg mehr gespielt
wegen dem was
ok ich habe die trigi gekriegt ist auch nicht schlecht von der ratte hat die die ausgekotzt
aber das ist doch der gleiche stap den lose auch schon dabei hat
dann muss ich mir den auch nicht kraften wo geht es denn hier lang
da ist ein schnellreise punkt mal gucken ob es hier wenigstens was gescheites drin ist
wir können auch auf unseren account spielen weil auf dem account geht nicht wenn ich auf
dem account spiele da komme ich jetzt erstmal mit master grandmaster ins game oder kacke
ich richtig ab nachdem ich jetzt drei sie sind nicht gespielt habe
jetzt habe ich sie alles verschlossen irgendein typ hat auch vorhin was von wer das erzählt
die else skin is pale as a corpses but his face contorts with inscrutable emotion joy
horror and rapture flash over him like the changing surface of a pond
his eyes lock onto yours it's you
lose you it's
ich weiß nicht ob wir overwatch spielen ich weiß nicht chat was sagt ihr soll man auch
noch eine runde overwatch spielen zu zweit
aber ich war noch ich habe drei sie sind nicht mal gespielt ich sage einfach nur ok
ok ich spiele gleich ich spiele gleich overwatch ich speichere jetzt hier noch aber eins wo
ich jetzt mal los werden das spiel hat echt liebe zum ds wurde wirklich mit viel liebe
zum detail hier entwickelt du kannst es so ich wette also man kann das alles wie ich
jetzt gespielt habe wahrscheinlich auf zehn verschiedene wege lösen und ich glaube auch
nicht dass es so gedacht ist dass ich hier mit die trischen durch den kerker stelzer
gerade das ist anders gedacht aber es geht und das ist das coole so ich muss jetzt erst
mal bettel netz starten nicht bettel viel bettel viel starten nein ich will nicht bettel
viel starten ich will bettel netz starten der will jetzt allen ernstes bettel viel drei
starten ja ich muss gerade noch mal update laden es dauert noch fünf minuten also es
ist auf jeden fall noch zeit so sein out quit origin bettel wie heißt das heißt es einfach
bettel nett app ne blizzard app heißt der krempel jetzt ja blizzard app ist es jetzt
ja ok startet destiny 2 overwatch ja ich muss erst mal ein overwatch patch laden das dauert
noch kurz ok ich habe gespeichert mal hier mal aus spiel ich dann nachher morgen oder
sonst wann weiter ich bin so was wie support man ja also meine besten char sind eindeutig
lucio ana senata da kann ich noch ein bisschen bisschen oft tanks spielen und so was so ich
muss jetzt erstmal overwatch patch erst mal overwatch patch installieren ihr seht das
dauert das ist nicht so schnell es geht halbwegs 10 mb die sekunde hoffentlich leckt das stream
jetzt nicht welche tastatur maus per tasto maus per habe ich ein rocket hero maus habe
ich eine soe z2a und das tatur habe ich nur an microsoft tastatur ich bin mit dem falschen
account eingeloggt sehe ich gerade muss gleich noch ändern
was stelle ich und was machen wir jetzt am besten wir machen jetzt ich muss jetzt umstellen
von 1920 auf 720p 60 fps so dann stellen wir schon mal edit overwatch
ich muss den stream gleich mal kurz ausmachen und wieder einschalten damit ich die auflösung
ändern kann das geht ja nicht on the fly brauchen wir noch einen guten streamtitel
was war die letzte season die wir gespielt haben ich glaube drei
ja es ist ja nicht mal gab ich starte mal ganz schnell den stream
in